my
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
hey it's us again it's saturday night
i gotta tell you though unfortunately i
can't get
totally shit-faced drunk on this no
she's gotta do another show because i
have to do another
live radio show yeah for into the pair
what it's into the para but normal with
a bee in the middle
yeah i don't get it but yeah so get
around them copyrights
i guess so but yeah i have to do a
two-hour live radio show with them at
like 10 p.m eastern time like it's right
at midnight as far as i know i don't
think i'm gonna be
like visible on it i kind of hope not
but we'll see
maybe you guys can look for it after
this show is over if you wanted to see
that one maybe
yeah i put a post a link or something i
did i put a link to
where uh where it all was and everything
like that so
so like i said i'm gonna really try and
not get i slept nice and late this
morning
and i'm gonna try not to get super super
hammered yeah
and try to leave myself a little gap in
between so i can go over my notes again
because i have to talk about like some
unsolved murders from my faceless
villain series i slept good last night i
don't know what it was woke up and it
was nearly noon
you were still sleeping i wasn't still
sleeping i was awake
i woke up at 10 something but
pookie had curled up right next to me
and i couldn't really get out of the bed
and she was too cute like to move her
yeah so i just kind of laid there awake
i'm telling you man
sleeping's been [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
mental attitude's been [ __ ] up just
energy level [ __ ] up that's the
symptoms of low t man
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go make a [ __ ]
i'm gonna i think i'm gonna make a
[ __ ]
uh uh a consultation with one of them
[ __ ]
hormone shacks get my own [ __ ] myself
[ __ ] jacked up on [ __ ]
testosterone
it says i want the testosterone for 14
year old boys
[Laughter]
see what that [ __ ] does and put some
blood of virgins in there
yeah replace my bone marrow with a bone
marrow and [ __ ]
pureed [ __ ] fetuses and [ __ ]
all that high-tech [ __ ] high-tech
vampirism [ __ ] that you guys are doing
the [ __ ] that you guys do to these rich
people you know
hiding out on these islands i know it's
not normal what you guys are doing
[Laughter]
some of them [ __ ] are in their
[ __ ] 80s and they're still running
around trying to make money
yeah trying to get all their blood
replaced yeah trying to make money and
trying to [ __ ]
you have all the money they'll do
whatever i don't know how much of it
like actually works or not but i
think it works i guess they figure
doctors are kind of like hey if you want
to cough up some
money i'll do whatever you want
evidently some of these rich people are
getting blood transfusions that come out
the blood comes out of teenagers going
through
which i can see how that might work
because real high quality blood
of your type with some kind of with
[ __ ] hormones in it you know what i
mean like you know they
the women get girl blood and the guys
get boy blood and i imagine would be
like [ __ ] trt
girl blood and boy yeah to try to
[ __ ] you know what i mean they're
doing countess bathory [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] hormones are [ __ ]
key man
that's how that [ __ ] works yeah you've
been talking about that all day i know
i'm telling you i did some of that lgd
4033 [ __ ] sarms
[ __ ] selective energy and receptor
modulators that's just [ __ ] gray
market stuff
i'm not saying don't do that don't do
that people but
for about a month maybe you'll feel
[ __ ] great and then you'll get real
[ __ ] sleepy and have to come off of
it you'll be bloated like a [ __ ]
blue like that girl that ate that
blueberry candy
you'll feel like that after i've had a
bargain but you feel good for a while
beezness says the vilo testosterone in
mexico is 150
hit me what up okay dude you will get
dude you just gave it away
because now you get in trouble with the
feds for sending that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] mail
that's all i need i need a vial of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'll shoot it myself
i don't even need the blood i don't even
need the blood work i'll just [ __ ]
light dose i'll be able to feel how much
i need light does
yeah [ __ ] um but yeah getting it here
you can get it through russia
but [ __ ] atf would be watching you
they'll probably show up [ __ ] where's
them files [ __ ] lock you up i ain't
[ __ ] around without you
i'm just gonna go get the [ __ ] from what
a doctor around here about maybe how to
get it from dr
matt said dr matt how much you want for
a [ __ ] prescription of that [ __ ]
i really don't need i really don't need
somebody to
do my blood work or i know and i'm not
gonna do anything exotic just basic [ __ ]
and victor very helpfully said i can
whip you up some baby batter for 20
[Laughter]
all right so louie louie asked when are
we going to be on conspiracy i don't
know
actually when they need us whenever they
they usually call us every now and then
yeah we went to [ __ ] red lobster
today
jenny said [ __ ] uh i said let's go out
and get something to eat
for the [ __ ] show and uh we hadn't
had seafood in a long time
yeah we couldn't decide where to go
we're like scrolling through my phone
going like man i don't know what i want
they had you know i wanted i wanted to
dine in [ __ ]
experience you know what i mean a lot of
places there they're being [ __ ]
they're being [ __ ] [ __ ] about that
still but
the one one a place that had the dining
in experience is red lobster
says man yeah we're gonna check that
[ __ ] out yeah we haven't sleep in a long
time i got the most expensive thing that
they had
what was that that that surf and tear
surf and tur the deluxe surf and turf
ultimate surf and turf
[Laughter]
man this [ __ ] was good it had uh lobster
tail
uh a filet mignon and some
bacon wrapped scallops on a skewer fully
loaded baked potato
caesar salad i can't believe this has a
40 meal man i can't believe you ate all
that
all that [ __ ] it was good it was it was
kind of small man the tail was kind of
small
i'm a little spoiled you know but the
tail was kind of small
the fillet was kind of small but the
quality was good
it really wasn't worth the 40 i don't
think i think
what you got was a better deal even
though i couldn't even like
have it yeah well i was i hadn't eaten
for like 24 hours so i was like wow i'm
really hungry and i really really want
some seafood
and so i got one of that i got that
platter where you can like
choose two or three things and then like
you get a couple sides
so i got a salad i got a baked potato i
didn't get a loaded baked potato i just
got like you know butter on it
yeah a little bit sour cream but um yeah
so i got like some
broiled scallops and then i got like
some coconut shrimp because that's my
favorite and then i got some fish i gave
the scallops
and most of the potato and one of the
shrimp
and then i was just like i can't eat
anymore yeah
i had to put it all in a box so i'm
gonna have to eat the rest of it
tomorrow
i went in and saw that for 20 bucks they
had fish and chips on there go check
them fish and chips next time i've heard
they were good
yeah i haven't been there in years and
years i don't know if the portions
if the portions hit good or not you know
i i you know
captain d's they give you a pretty big
portion yeah that's
like captain d's we go there sometimes
too if you want fried seafood
yeah and they have like fried green
tomatoes and like southern kind of [ __ ]
yes other stuff yeah but
their portions are so big too that it's
like you get a regular platter there and
i can't eat
it trust captains though they got black
people cooking back there you go there
just everybody works there's black
you got this is a southern [ __ ]
restaurant here it is yeah like it's
southern here yeah and it's [ __ ]
sweet tea and everything
they know yeah they have all they know
just what they're doing it's not
corporate
it's not just [ __ ] i mean it is it's
a chain but
it's a chain but it's not like cisco
stuff where it's just frozen stuff and
then do it they're they're
they're battering it and deep frying it
they're making it they're seasoning it i
could tell they got okra and stuff
yeah like fried okra we haven't been
there in a while but like i said it's
it's only something i can do every now
and then because as much as like
like i said we went to red lobster today
my thing was 25
but i could only eat about half of it
maybe not even half
and then so i had to put the rest of it
in a box and like bring it home and even
the portion that i ate um my stomach is
still upset
because that was like way way way too
much food
so okay so the red lobster got a
commercial and [ __ ] captain d's got a
commercial
i said captain d's still around i mean
we still have it here
it's about uh about six seven miles up
the road
we have one you're not talking about
long john silver's or anything or
actually captain d's used to be pretty
bad didn't it
i don't know i don't think there are
another captain this one it
it doesn't taste it doesn't taste and
look like a corporate chain it look it
looks
more kind of like you can tell it's a
chain but it doesn't
it's not like going to mcdonald's or
something you know i mean they're
actually
they're actually hand battering that the
the seafood and frying it yeah i can
tell it's not pretty frozen
[ __ ] might be but i don't think so
no i don't think so i am well i imagine
the fish comes in frozen and then they
just
but i don't think it's pre-battered yeah
it might not be like
it looked like it was looked like they
battered it after it was thawed
yeah and um same with the shrimp
so i think they're hand battered yeah
probably
yeah i think so which yeah red mage was
saying long john silver is still around
too
yeah i think what's happened we i think
we have one
just around here somewhere but it's
isn't it like half of a taco belt like
half taco bell and half long done
silver's i think because like all of
those are
i get them confused sometimes long john
silvers was pretty bad it was always
pretty bad
i actually used to you know what i used
to like back in the old days arthur
treacher
yeah i don't even know if they have that
anymore the last time i saw one of those
was a few years ago in an
airport it used to be like a sit-down
restaurant when i was a kid and i used
to really really like it
long john silver's had a damn corporate
generic taste to it you can tell all
right
um our lea our captain d's here it
tastes like a mom-pop place
to me yeah i like it yeah
yeah we go there every now and then like
i said it's just it's so much food and
it's like
so so fattening yeah yeah well it's
going to be fatty but yeah
i know but it's so so good yeah and you
know it's always pretty busy
yeah nothing but just [ __ ] work crews
and rednecks and chips i can go in there
and eat
hush puppies and [ __ ] that's the way it
is
beezness as uh says i think we still
have a half a
w and half long john silver's yeah maybe
it is a w
i can't remember i thought it was taco
bell i could be remembering
sometimes taco bell this time yeah but
well because like i said i think they're
all
owned by the same company you know we
tried to go to one remember it was a
taco bell
half and half and it was closed for some
reason
or the or the long john silver's was
closed but the taco bell was still open
yeah and i was like [ __ ] up because we
went through the drive through and we're
like hey man i want some fried fish and
they're like nope long john's oversized
clothes let's see who's here
zach sam t's in what's up t
t did you see blacula okay or maybe she
already saw that
because we were talking about it last
year yeah i thought i thought she said
so sam
michael b's nest
everybody's here yeah um
yeah i got nearly 40 people just piling
in
um some people talking about the show
um
trey simmons he said uh the uh these two
topics are some of his favorites here i
still can't believe that we haven't
covered flight 19. well somebody
somebody recommended that we do the
ghost blimp
which i didn't actually really i guess i
had kind of heard about a long time ago
but i've forgotten about it and i was
like well [ __ ] that's like a really cool
case
and then i was like well in case it
doesn't go i don't think we can get a
whole show out of that so i said well
let's talk about flight 19 because
that's like really mysterious and yeah
uh i don't think we ever covered that i
don't think we really
covered a lot of bermuda triangle stuff
did we michael schaefer said that
they found flight 19 in mars orbit
that's a good one well then they they
made a reference to flight 19 and uh
close encounters of the third kind did
they not well yeah they returned the
planes and then later on the crew
yeah yeah that's not really what
happened they're asking if i still have
lead in my pencil yeah i got lead in the
pen
i might need to sharpen that pencil up a
little bit
no it's just you know
file testosterone's a [ __ ] 150 up
mexico
damn yeah probably don't even you
probably don't even need a uh
um prescription over there either
that would simplify things a lot
zach says i think long john silver's is
the nastiest place i've ate at
yeah it's not that good it was okay when
it was
when i was a kid teen said she saw black
latons didn't see the doctor sleep
director's cut yet
they're making you pay for the whole
damn movie yeah all right this is what i
did
i got i i bought the blu-ray i used
blu-ray off of
um i think it was i think it was it was
ebay it's either ebay or it was uh
amazon i bought a used one in excellent
condition
that came with the blu-ray and the dvd
i think for seven dollars delivered and
that was cheaper than the rental
you know amazon so i just bought it a
hard copy of it
i used them and it was good
yeah louis says no prescription needed
in mexico for anything
damn the business said it's a 400
milliliter vial too
damn it yeah i'm gonna get you in
trouble
you have to like meet up somewhere
that's probably a month's worth two
months worth depending on what
the concentration is you're gonna have
to
do it all on the dl actually 150 the
concentration is probably pretty high
it's probably about three months worth
yeah yeah i hate the way this little
thing keeps going around it makes me
really nervous
it says i have an excellent connection
so and we did we did the whole show
wednesday night without dropping out
right yeah we were on for like five
hours under trump didn't drop out
yeah we'll see though
zach said uh i legit finished a meal
there and feared i was gonna have a
stroke like peter griffin after he eat
40 hamburgers
all right because we got two is there
any shout outs we need to do
i don't think so okay we don't have any
new patrons or anything like that
um there's nothing else i don't think we
don't think there's anything else we had
to mention we should just go ahead and
get in the show
because you got to do another show after
this one yeah and we don't want it to
run too
long yeah because otherwise i'll be
otherwise you [ __ ]
just jump out of the show i'll be drunk
and worn out and then i'll have to
you know i want to kind of go through my
notes again right
you know for that before i you know do
whatever i know
both of these cases uh matter of fact
dude that's good
the ghost blimp i think happened uh near
my house in long beach i think they
happened
off the coast of long beach did it oh
thanks victor where i was born
um it was san francisco bay san
francisco bay okay so
up north all right yeah i knew it was on
the coast of california but i thought it
might have been
long beach or or you know some or
uh what else yeah i thought was long
beach but okay yeah it was right around
the golden gate bridge actually thanks
victor
thank you victor yep the shout out to
him
[Laughter]
visa says it's safe to ship i mailed
some to my brother yeah
all right man we're talking
we're not real master criminals yeah
no i got to look more into it and see
what you know
is what how it's classified
yeah i mean yeah i don't know [ __ ]
what the classification is
[ __ ] have that you [ __ ] send it to
me and then all of a sudden federal
agents [ __ ] come
jumping through the damn window trying
to get some good pr
for the [ __ ] waco team and [ __ ] they
jump in [ __ ] machine gun me down
because i'm trying to [ __ ] you know
what i mean [ __ ]
reverse some [ __ ] reverse some
[ __ ] hormonal biological
they want to kill a [ __ ] over it
no you can't look good
i gotta see i don't see how much they
want for it here and
how how to get it here hey look we have
a michael shaffer with two
f's and a michael shafer with one f
that's pretty weird okay what are the
odds
i don't know that we would have that we
would have two listeners that have the
same name
except slightly different they're
talking to each other
yeah well that would be you know that
would be like if we had somebody else
that
you know with my name that turned up in
the thing champions said they'll club me
like a babysitter
[Laughter]
oh no victor says bee's nest can swallow
it and then go use the bathroom at your
house
that's a pretty good idea and he has to
do this every couple months
so you got to have it you got to have a
[ __ ] lifetime reliable lifetime
supply of it
you know i gotta there's there's a place
right up right up the [ __ ] road here
that does it
um [ __ ] what'd they call it
is it some kind of men's health [ __ ]
men's health [ __ ]
clinton rebuild your life men's health
clinics some [ __ ] like
they have all those good [ __ ] all the
good drugs up there that they'll give to
men
and um yeah they should do a mobile one
called the man band
yeah i just want to know whether or not
you gotta go up there [ __ ] twice a
week to get shots
and i mean i don't want to do that and
then i want to see what the price is
yeah
you know what i mean i can i can shoot
it myself i got i'm trained for it
i can give myself ivs
give all kinds of drugs to [ __ ]
horses thoroughbreds i should have got
all that
[ __ ] equipos when it was around yeah
we had this we had this good [ __ ] at the
bar called echo pose
equipo is [ __ ] like horse
testosterone
if a horse ever went lame or got injured
or anything like that you shoot him up
with that and [ __ ] they'd be healed
up in about two days
it was good [ __ ] it it [ __ ] a man up
though
i've heard or it'd make you big get big
real quick
you're gonna start winning make it
[ __ ] crazy too make it crazy
[ __ ] up your cholesterol well you don't
need that yeah
well if you weren't too long you just
take therapeutic doses
of it michael shaffer was one of those
they were there were women in the horse
industry that were taken into real
[ __ ] light
therapeutic doses make the ass big
[Laughter]
make your legs and your ass [ __ ] huge
yeah no you know but well you know what
i mean not
you build up a lot of muscle build up
and also possibly grow a tail
what's it no it's just an anabolic
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] shoot that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] and then do a few squats a day
[ __ ] ride horses and [ __ ] sling
hay bales around and girls asses get
[ __ ] huge on that
yeah yeah michael shaffer with one f
just said we've both been here for a
while i think this is the first time you
guys have noticed
but there i i kind of i suspect that
they're the same person though
look because michael shafer with one f
says michael schaefer with two f's is an
esteemed fellow and a genius
[Laughter]
i don't know what the hell kind of
chicanery and shenanigans are going on
in the chat do a show about women and
horses
that might kind of be interesting you
know how you know how teenage girls and
horses are
yeah there's some kind of sexual thing
going on there it's pretty weird i mean
it's not universal but it is
pretty common i remember being really i
collected all the
you know horse statues and [ __ ] like
that he's jumping in with a [ __ ]
ultimate black girl question what
happened to them just playing old squats
next she's going to ask me about her
hair and [ __ ]
okay white dudes don't don't care about
your hair man [ __ ] they kind of like
the big [ __ ] afros and [ __ ] don't
worry about the [ __ ] flats and don't
worry about [ __ ] extensions all right
and when it comes to the [ __ ] squats
i'm telling you this is an old trick
a lot of these uh bodybuilder girls know
all about it
they're [ __ ] with hormones of
different kinds of hormones one of them
is just uh anabolics and certain
testosterone
type compounds it's a bunch of different
ones
um no if you've got
the the can the compound correct and the
dosage correct and the right kind of
workout
what the hell who the hell keeps calling
that's off
if you've got everything right um
you get [ __ ] fat [ __ ] a huge ass
it's it's just supernatural i'll show
you
i'll show you oh he's going to show them
i'm going to show you i'll show you
individual girls
we are going to get to the topic but
people are talking about ass
victor's telling me to write down mr
hands mr hands
do a show about mr hands
i don't know i'll write down mr hands
what's mr hands i don't know
we'll see
tom will show us porn now no it's not
far
okay
come on there's like there's like dead
time that's what anabolics will do
to a woman
okay those are legs you can't get legs
any other way than in a box i'll show it
from the back
thank you zach i dare you to drink for
you and jenny i want to see how smashed
you can get
yeah tom what's that no he wants
he wants you to drink for both of us so
you can get really super hammerish
same woman oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
texas that's terrifying
same girl that's anabolics
they're not an ounce of fat in that
that's all muscle it's ridiculous
supernatural [ __ ] yeah supernatural
michael schaefer says hard pass throw
down said i got no problem with a sturdy
girl
name is bakar nabiva sturdy yeah
where else on a show about ghost blimps
those are two ghost blimps one right now
all right let's go ahead and start this
show off i think everybody's here i
think they're ready for the show
yeah and let's get
um you know you know something about
these two cases
yeah i know about this case so that's
pretty good so you can help me out if i
get although i have notes over here
all right so we're going back to
august 16th 1942.
it was a sunday now
there's a u.s navy blimp called l8
or love 8. and it was going to take off
from treasure island in san francisco
bay
and its job on this day just like most
of its other jobs on
other days was to look for enemy
submarines
now at this point in august of 1942
the u.s had only um entered world war ii
about nine months
previously but there had already been a
lot of incidents where
japanese subs had sunk a bunch of allied
ships
off of the west coast of the united
states so
there were a lot of blimp patrols going
around looking for enemy
subs japanese submarines um you know
in the pacific off the coast of
california
so so basically that's
kind of what uh what was going on so
this particular
blimp um was actually
carrying two 325 pound
uh depth charge bombs just in case they
saw some submarines it shouldn't be
there uh they also had a 30 caliber
machine gun
and 300 rounds of ammunition so
if they saw a submarine sneaking around
out there off the pacific coast
then they could take them out yeah what
year was this again 1942
okay yeah world war ii yeah coastal yes
yep that's what it was yeah so
the blimp takes off the l8 um
with a two-man crew which i guess was
standard procedure um it was lieutenant
ernest
dewitt cody and ensign charles
ellis adams uh both were
navy veterans and uh had
apparently exemplary service records
now interestingly so cody
was the younger guy he was only 32. he
had graduated from annapolis
he was um senior aviator of the airship
patrol squadron
and he was apparently considered one of
the most capable
uh pilots of lighter-than-air transport
or lta as they called it
um although he didn't have i guess he
didn't have as much flight time in them
as the other guy
had uh he didn't get to be a naval
airship
aviator until december of 1941 so he'd
only been flying them for
about uh nine months at the point that
this incident occurred
um now interestingly
the other guy adams
was 11 years older and was actually kind
of a lot more
uh were or was a lot less experienced
now the pilot of the blimp um
cody had only 706
wait a minute okay so the guy
the guy that was the the pilot of the
blimp had less flight time than the guy
that was like the second in command
yeah that's what it seemed like and like
the guy that was the pilot was younger
that's what i would that's what i'm
gonna say so the pilot only had 756
hours
of blimp flight time and adams the other
guy had over
2 000 hours of flight time um
and the other guy had also actually
flown an
l8 before he had actually taken it
to they were delivering stuff to the uss
hornet
and so he had to kind of like hover over
the
aircraft carrier or whatever and they
were like you know hold it steady over
there while they were lowering stuff
down onto the aircraft carrier
yeah to make it make things clear these
these observation blimps that these guys
were using
they weren't very big we're not talking
about the hindenburg which is a gigantic
super liner these things were actually
pretty small
well this was this was essentially a
goodyear blimp yeah it was made for that
before the war and then it was
uh commandeer they weren't that big they
were the size of maybe like a couple box
cars
yeah yeah four or five of them maybe i
think that's more or less
i don't remember them being very big
they look kind of big in the air
yeah but they're nothing compared to you
know like i said like the hindenburg
right they're pretty small yeah and it's
weird because uh speaking of the
hindenburg
the um adams had actually received
uh he got decorated by the german
government for helping
hindenburg passengers during that when
that crashed
so he was over there during that so like
i said he actually had more flight time
in uh blimps than the other guy had but
they were both they had both flown them
before you know what i mean so it's not
like they were
they didn't know what they were doing
yeah and um all these
all these lighter-than-air aircraft
originals [ __ ]
blimps zeppelins that's another way to
come they were all
super dangerous they sucked you really
didn't want one wanna fly one
just to say that's why they don't use
them much anymore yeah very dangerous
zach asked if we'd done a show on the
hindenburg i you know it i don't think
we have nothing really mysterious about
it
true it's like this case is interesting
because because yeah this is kind of
like something that would happen to see
it's because it's kind of weird and like
you know it's a disappearance
they were dangerous but but there this
one isn't there isn't really a clear
explanation for what happened with this
you know yeah i just have suspicions
i mean something happened obviously but
it just seems like no one really knows
what exactly it was
they were too big they're lighter than
air uh they're real susceptible to uh
climate bad weather that's that's the
main problems with these things
yeah and a lot of times they were being
suspended by gases that were flammable
yeah and hence hindenburg
yeah inside the inside the zeppelin
itself you know it wasn't one big open
it wasn't one big old open thing it was
like a bunch of cells you could shoot
bullets through them they would hold gas
because it would only pop certain cells
they had waste so that really wasn't the
danger the danger was uh
getting caught in storms and you know
lightning strikes stuff like that
yeah but yeah so so like i said even
though
these weren't you know but
they were like experienced one was less
experienced than the other but they had
actually like flown these types of uh
airships before ensign adams uh matter
of fact
uh had been flying them for 20 years and
um
he'd served aboard like three different
uh
you know blimps and as i said he was
also helped to get some of the people
off the hindenburg when that exploded
so they they both knew what they were
doing so
this particular day this particular
flight um
was called flight 101 and what they were
supposed to do
was they were supposed to take off from
treasure island they were supposed to
fly to the farallon islands which are 30
miles west of san francisco
then they're supposed to go north to
point reyes
and then south to monterra beach and
then returning to treasure island so
they're going out and around
now this patrol was supposed to take
four hours
they were starting out about six in the
morning so they were expected back
between 10 and 10 30 in the morning
a flight went off without a hitch the
you know weather was fine visibility was
decent
um so no one really thought anything
about it because like i said it was just
a very very routine
patrol now um as i mentioned earlier
this particular blimp
uh was made by uh goodyear
and had been used as part of their like
advertising from before you know what i
mean just like the goodyear blimp they
have nowadays
um and then when world war ii came along
you know they a lot of them were
commissioned for the war and uh
matter of fact after this incident
happened um
after the war was over this particular
blimp was actually put back into service
by goodyear
and i think it went until like even at
some sporting events and [ __ ] like that
like up until the 1980s
before it was retired i think it's in a
museum in pensacola now if i'm not
mistaken um but yeah so so this is just
your regular
goodyear blimp essentially um now this
particular
airship the l8 um it had
it had done over a thousand uh trips
and had required none
nothing out of the ordinary just the
regular maintenance
and uh was supposedly a good airship
nothing
no problems with it anything like that
um it had also had an
inspection four days prior to this
incident
occurring and seemed to be in perfect
working
order again that is going to be
significant
so 6 03 a.m um thank you ken
just because that's always the best
reason thank you so much
appreciate it that's gonna help pay for
my [ __ ] testosterone
it'll wake me up man jenny could tell
you i'm just getting slowed down slowed
down like an old man
just all negative yeah negative
yeah yeah you need to snap out of the
snap out of being negative
[Laughter]
drink more you'll be able to be fine i
gotta get another drink here in a minute
i'm okay i'll tell you i'll let you run
this show and i'll get some more to keep
i mean it's only 5 30. i got hornidos
tonight man
yeah he got the good [ __ ] just the spice
is the spicy [ __ ]
it's the spicy [ __ ]
all right so um so adams and cody
take off about 603 am in the l8
uh winds light and variable four knots
per hour
um weather slightly overcast but uh
visibility was good out to three to five
miles
and uh cody reported he could even see
the golden gate bridge in the distance
which
you know if you're from san francisco
you can't always say that because you
know like i said it's [ __ ] foggy all
the time
but today not so much it was it was
pretty visible
so as i said they had to go on a patrol
it was a 50 mile radius
around san francisco now so what ends up
happening
is that they pass over the golden gate
bridge
um and then turn toward the south west
toward the farallon islands
now about an hour and a half into the
patrol
which was about 7 38 a.m
there was uh he radioed in cody did
and said that they were four miles east
of the farallon
islands now four minutes after that
they got um there was another radio
message
this one said am investigating
suspicious
oil slick stand by now
again this wasn't strange but an oil
slick
could indicate obviously an enemy
submarine
somewhere in the vicinity so that was
one of the things that they were trained
to look out for if you saw an oil slick
on the water you had to go check it out
because there might be
an enemy submarine underneath the waves
so what so what they ended up doing is
they
kind of lowered two of their uh they're
kind of like smoke flares they're like
lights you know
so they lowered those down so they could
get a better look
at whatever it was that was going on
under the water um
these were lowered at 7 42 am the flares
so they start scrutinizing the area
now another nearby ship a liberty ship
called the albert gallatin
um saw the flares coming down from the
blimp
now the crew of this ship since they
figured hey maybe they found a submarine
so they sounded an alarm and you know
got all the
gunners you know to their positions and
everything like that
now there was also another ship in the
area which was a fishing
trawler called the daisy gray um
and they knew the same thing they were
kind of like oh [ __ ] like a submarine's
about to get bombed
we need to get the [ __ ] out of here so
they pulled up their nets
and you know started to kind of go back
towards shore
but interestingly the blimp didn't drop
any bombs
so l8 the blimp it just kind of circled
around where the supposed oil slick was
for about an hour
um the blimp was apparently close enough
to the fishing ship
the or the trawler that the first mate
could look through his binoculars and he
could see the
the two guys inside the blimp inside the
gondola right
he could see it in there he'd see them
in there
so everything seemed normal
at this point like i said they you know
they see an oil slick they put lights
down because maybe it's an enemy sub
and then they're just kind of circling
around so apparently they don't see us
they don't see anything because they're
not dropping any bombs or anything like
that
so now the crew of the daisy gray which
was the fishing trawler
and um the albert gallatin which was the
other ship they're
what they were watching the blimp
through binoculars because they were
like i wonder what's going on over there
so the l8 is circling
uh at 200 to 300 feet at one point it
lowers to about thirty feet above the
surface of the water
um as though they were looking more
closely at something
and this went on for quite a while then
um a little after nine in the morning
the blimp dropped ballast
rose up and headed back towards san
francisco
now as i said no one on the ships or
anything like that thought anything was
weird because they were used to
seeing blimps patrolling this area all
the time and
the crews of the other ships probably
just like oh well they thought they saw
a submarine and there wasn't one so
they're just continuing their patrol so
they didn't think anything was strange
but this was pretty much the last normal
thing that happened that day
like once the ship started heading back
towards san francisco
now as i mentioned the last radio
message
that cody had sent was at 7 42 a.m and
this was right before
like when he was saying about the oil
slick and we're lowering the flares and
blah blah
they didn't um contact anyone after that
on the radio
um now wing control tried to
call them like try to you know rise them
on the radio
but couldn't uh get them couldn't get
anybody to answer
um now apparently the squadron
headquarters didn't find out
about the blimp being like
non-responsive or they're being radio
silence
until 8 20 a.m but again no one thought
this was all that weird because it
wasn't
that unusual to lose radio contact with
the blimps like during routine patrols
and they
figured well it'll come back at some
point or whatever
um they also weren't worried because
the two guys there was plenty of fuel on
the blimp
um you know so they weren't going to run
out or anything like that
but um they started to think it was a
little weird around 8
50. so it was like like i said almost
nine o'clock um because they were like
look we can't raise them it's like we
don't know where they are
so they sent a couple of uh float planes
out to look for the blimp and
kind of sent out a general alert for
other aircraft in the area hey
if you see where this blimp is just let
us know what's going on with it because
we can't raise anybody on the radio
now the next sighting of the blimp
wasn't for quite a while
the next one came it was the 10 49 am
now this was a pilot of a pan-american
clipper
and he said that he saw the blimp over
the golden gate bridge
now he said it doesn't look like
anything's wrong with it
it looks like it's you know i'm still
under human control
and it's operating normally and it's
moving
back toward the base where it's supposed
to be going even though like i said it
was a little later than they were
expecting it back
but it didn't look like there was
anything the matter with it at this
point
about 10 minutes later
one of the float planes the pilot of one
of the float planes
saw the blimp three miles west of solata
beach
and it was rising up through the sky
um and it was about 2000 feet it went up
like 2000 feet and then it came back
down
and kind of like disappeared into the
clouds
now the pilot thought this was a little
weird because
even though it still looked like it was
under human power
um they said 2000 feet of altitude
that's close to the blimp's pressure
height
um that's where the valves would open
and vent helium
it's not really supposed to you know go
up that high
um so but it did it went up that high
but then it came back down
it's yeah so he's so he thought that was
a little bit unusual but he said it
didn't look like it was
um you know messed up or anything like
that see
when it the higher something might would
go in under the circumstances the more
it would expand so they don't want to
rupture all the [ __ ] cells
all right bladders inside the damn
zeppelin in the balloon
so it would vent if it went up to that
altitude so i already got
warning bells going off they saw it
gaining altitude to its maximum
safe ceiling and then dropping it was
unmanned there's nobody in there
that's what happened yeah well
it's really i don't know it's just it's
really really weird it sounds like there
was no one in control
that maybe nobody was in that zeppelin
at this point
and then it blew off it blew off it
blew off kind of the over pressure
valves invented it's it's it's it's
helium and then it
made a descent back to the earth yes
in weather conditions there's wind
blowing too
you know these things aren't moving very
fast and they're kind of at the mercy of
the winds and climate
so they could cover a large distance
without having anybody in
them okay go ahead i know how this thing
was found i remember how they found this
thing and you know the audience don't
know doesn't know what's going on yet
but go ahead and tell them yeah right
so um now again a little bit later
um another uh person saw the blimp a
p-38 pilot
yeah and he saw it near mile rock
um again notice nothing amiss it didn't
seem to be adrift
it still seemed to be under human power
uh human control
um he assumed it was heading back to
treasure island which was where the base
was so he didn't again think of anything
strange um but then a couple minutes
after
that there was a dude he was a seaman
but he was off duty his name was richard
quam
and he was actually going to spend the
day at the beach and he was driving
along the highway
between san mateo and san francisco and
he saw the blimp in the distance now at
this point he noticed that the blimp
was bent in the middle um and he
really quick like whipped out his camera
and took a picture of it which like i
said you can still see if you
google it um yeah it does look like it's
just kind of like
deflated a bit in the middle
so then 11 15 a.m which was five hours
after the blimp had left the base in the
morning uh the blimp comes toward
the shore on ocean beach in san
francisco
now at this point there was someone on
the beach and they noticed
that the blimp was hanging like 50 feet
offshore and its motors
were not running you couldn't hear
anything
and the the bag like the you know the
blind portion of it was
sagging and it was only about 50 feet
above the water now at this point the
blimp
um touched down on the sand a little bit
and then started moving
inland and then the gondola hit
kind of a hill and the engine
kind of got clogged with leaves and dirt
and stuff and bent the propellers like
when it hit this little hill
um interestingly too when it hit the
hill
one of the depth charges uh came loose
and kind of rolled down the hill like on
this beach or whatever
um now after that because the depth
charge weighed 325 pounds
since the weight came off the blimp the
blimp what kind of went up again
and kind of went out of sight for a
little while
now um going through a crash landing
phase
yeah and so okay so then there were a
bunch of golfers
at the olympic club and they could see
the blimp and they stopped to watch it
um now they saw the depth charge come
off and they kind of freaked out because
they were like is that [ __ ] gonna blow
up are we all gonna get blown up or
whatever
um but that wasn't gonna happen that's
it's it's fine
um it actually because that those depth
charges they can only be detonated with
like water pressure right so it's if it
drops on land it's not gonna do anything
well there's gonna be a fuse yeah drop
it and it's gonna go through an arming
sequence
and then you know i mean the fuse is
gonna be probably set for a certain
depth there's a procedure
just dropping a damn depth charge isn't
it you know coming off of its mount
isn't enough to set it off
right yeah so but you know they didn't
know that so they were just kind of like
well [ __ ] and then they were kind of
like freaking out about it
all anything that you sling underneath a
wing of an aircraft or on an aircraft
it's got a whole safety procedure you're
not running around with something that's
just ready to down blow
well yeah because that would be it's too
[ __ ] stupid
even back in world war ii they knew how
to safely carry [ __ ] bombs yeah
but yeah so interestingly though
um one of the golfers later reported
that he saw a parachute
coming off of the blimp while it was
still offshore
i have reason to doubt this that maybe
he was seeing something else
um were they equipped with parachutes
yes
they were but spoiler alert later when
they looked that all the parachutes were
still on board
okay so obviously so he must have seen
something else
yeah um now interesting or he made it up
but like i said there might have been
something else falling off of there that
he saw that he missed
it's going to be the evidence inside and
the procedure and all the procedures
they went through
that's that's how you're going to figure
out how what happened yeah
yeah so now interestingly though at this
point
after and again i'm not sure how much i
believe this account i'm not saying that
people are lying i'm just saying that
maybe they're mistaken or they saw it at
a different time
there was this other kid that was
looking at because you have to think
when this blimp was going through this
whole
like crash procedure that it was going
through there was like hundreds
thousands of people
like out on the beach fishing it was a
sunday so like you know out golfing
people driving around like on the
highway and [ __ ] like so it's not like
this happened and nobody was around to
see it a whole bunch of people saw it
um so they have a whole bunch of
different um witnesses to it
so now there was this one kid who
was watching it through his binoculars
and he said i believe
even while the blimp was uh kind of
limping along
that he still saw two guys inside the
gondola
because you know you can see you can see
in there like you can see people moving
around
um but i'm not sure if he saw them at
this stage or not
he probably saw the seats or something
maybe i'm not real sure
um so like i said there's thousands of
people around watching this thing
because
they're like hey look it's crashing so
everybody is
always violent crash no these guys have
the training and the sound mind they
would if
if this was some kind of if it was
crashing beyond their control the way
they're describing this damn crash they
just would have rode it out they'd have
been all right
yeah so yeah i mean even when they hit
the hill it wasn't like
it was kind of like yeah no they left
they left they left that gondola a long
time before that thing ever crashed
they left it before it [ __ ] gained
all the altitude and blew off all that
extra gas yeah tila said it would be
freaky to see that happening
it would be i would think well evidently
it was because a lot of people were just
kind of like what the [ __ ]
they weren't in there for a long time
and i think i kind of know what happened
but go ahead
okay so um so i guess there were like
some dudes from like the fire department
of daly city
and they were um they were right nearby
because they were burning some brush so
they came and ran and to help and like
the cops came and all this other kind of
stuff
like i said there's thousands of people
standing around watching this kind of
stuff like on the beach and everything
and um so by this point uh
the blimp is kind of going down toward
uh daly city um two blocks south of san
francisco
the san francisco county line it kind of
went over some people's roofs
um there was a woman named ethel
appleton and she heard the drag line
going across her roof um also there was
another dude
who he was actually waxing his car in
his front driveway
and i think the blimp ended up just like
falling on his car he was okay though
like he ran inside and stuff like that
so uh about 11 30 in the morning
the blimp finally came to a stop in the
middle of the 400 block of bellevue
avenue now it wasn't a real a super soft
landing it actually did
um hit a utility pole and
uh kind of broke off across arm of the
pole
and what ended up happening too was that
the tail
of the blimp went into the electrical
wires so like a whole bunch of sparks
uh went off now at this point you know
obviously the fuel supply could have
ignited uh luckily it did not
um but the the you know blimp portion
had been punctured
and it just kind of went and kind of
slid to the ground tail
first slowly deflating on top of that
dude's car
um so they so
obviously this once it's come to a stop
and they've determined that it's not
going to blow up and everything like
that so
their first thought is well we have to
rescue the the crew because they thought
that they were still
in there so
the guy that was i think his name was
william morris and he was a firefighter
and he was kind of the first one and he
rushes up to the gondola and kind of
climbs in there
and then he's like um you guys nobody's
in here
nobody was in there yeah so the door was
open but there was nobody
in the cab um the door to the cabin had
been latched open
um the microphone for the loudspeaker
system
which is what they used to talk to like
ships you know when they were flying
around
that was dangling outside of the doorway
um but other than that it didn't look
real weird in there
well now what they well then they said
well maybe they got like up in the
you know in the envelope somehow so they
slashed that open and then they were
looking for the crew inside there
but the two dudes were
completely gone um
so basically the it's like some of the
authorities came they recovered the
depth charge and got that out of the way
because everybody was freaking out about
that
can only be one thing they left the
gondola
well obviously yes but nobody knows
where they went
they went in the water
well yeah duh but i'm just saying nobody
ever found them which is which is weird
yeah okay go ahead so um yeah so
basically
this is so strange because no one really
knows at what point i mean obviously
they both came out of the gondola at
some point and the gondola and the
blimp was flying around without human
without a human pilot
for quite a while but nobody knows
why they weren't in the gondola nobody
knows at what point
they left the gondola or for what reason
um
it's just like a real weird story okay
so uh
the blimp was obviously being um you
know tracked ship saw it
uh you know other planes saw it people
on the ground saw it everything saw it
um there were rumors swirling around
that there were still like a half-eaten
sandwich and like a warm coffee like
still in the gondola i know what they're
getting which
which is that's not true they're getting
that from that
from that other case that was similar to
this where you found that ship
the ship with all the going on its own
with all the uneaten food and
what happened to them actually
it is a similar case and i think it
might have been a similar type of
situation
yeah in the case of that ship i don't
know if you guys
maybe somebody in the comment section
might remember the name of that ship and
the name of that case
i remember what when you're told we
might have talked about it on one
because didn't we do a ghost ship show
yeah ship was found at sea i don't
remember if it was under power or not
because i don't think it was a sailboat
was it
i can't remember i don't think it was a
sailing ship it might have been a steam
ship or something yeah
but uh it was found at sea
fully unmanned but with uneaten food and
just no disturbances at all
but it was trailing a rope that's right
yeah
and um one of the uh we did talk about
that
and one of the uh the lifeboats was
missing
and in the case of that but there was
nothing wrong with the boat that's why
it was mysterious
yeah and they were carrying a cargo that
was some kind of kerosene wasn't it
or something impregnated with kerosene
something that might have
potentially been flammable or had some
kind of a gas
involved in it it wasn't the mary
celeste now no
in that particular case i think they
abandoned ship because they thought they
had to and they were allowing the ship
to trail
to trail their um a lifeboat
by a rope and then the rope broke
yeah that's what i think happened with
that one
and crew never found ship recovered
strange ghost ships at sea not a
not not not a bit of damage with
evidently food
set at the table see that kind of thing
is always way more creepy to me
because it's like obviously if you find
a ghost ship and everything's all [ __ ]
up in there and it looks like everybody
was like oh [ __ ] something bad happened
we got to get off
that's not mysterious like even if they
never find the bodies i'm like because
you know everybody probably fell in and
sharks ate them or whatever
but whenever you see something like this
where it doesn't look like anything's
wrong with the ship it doesn't look like
anyone was
cognizant of any issues about it and it
just seemed suddenly everyone got up in
the middle of dinner and just like fell
off the side of the boat
now i don't know if the if this if the
if the
if the food out set at the table
was a legend or not but that
was a legend that i think made its way
into this case
the whole idea of uneaten sandwiches and
sandwiches and [ __ ] that they're trying
to tell you the same thing because it's
a similar case yeah
i mean that was a rumor that came about
in the 40s um
yeah they later determined that that
wasn't i think what happened in the case
of that ship
though is i think they smelled something
that they thought was a gas leak
and as a precaution they went out into
the lifeboat to let the gases dissipate
but for somehow the rope broke and the
ship
left them yeah they couldn't catch up to
it ever again
which meant that they all died of thirst
in that damn
it's a shitty way to go yeah they all
ended up dying of thirst and insanity
in that [ __ ] boat that little dinghy
what do you call it lifeboat
yeah don't [ __ ] with the ocean okay
that's that's the
listen just don't go on the ocean for
anything i'm an old infantryman
i like to have a [ __ ] ground i could
even deal with being an aircraft crewman
back in world war ii the wall turret
gunner they didn't put my little ass in
the [ __ ] ball turret you're a little
ass yeah they put my little ass
that's what that's where they put the
little ass [ __ ] put that [ __ ]
in the ball turret is the worst place to
be
because they had people landing on the
ball turret once the [ __ ] hydraulics
were shot out they couldn't land the
damn [ __ ] landing gear
sorry ball turret we gotta land yeah
imagine that
because there's no way out yep well in
one case there was no way out because
the ball turret [ __ ] was all shot out
and they couldn't get him out of it
remember down in there begging while
they were landing on him that's awesome
that's terrible that's that's just gotta
be a horrible yeah way to go
but what are you gonna do that's what i
mean you got all those other guys in the
plane
yeah you know i mean at that point if i
feel like if you're in the
tour you might as well just like shoot
yourself yeah you'd probably be
you don't have anything except 250. i
know you can't point them out yourself
because it's like hey sorry man you
think you could have tried to cartwheel
it in on one wing give the guy a damn
chance
yeah but you know no they just landed on
that guy that was during the thick of
the damn war though
back when life was real cheap and i
don't think those guys knew each other
that well in that particular case
but anyway i'm getting all subject
i think what happened to this blimp was
something similar to that
is there anything else you want to talk
about the blimp before i give my phone
okay go ahead and you tell them
you tell them let me go let's hear their
theories let me let me go in i don't
here's the the devil in with this case
the devil is going to be in the details
yes you have to know what the mission
was and what all the procedures were
that the crew had to do for this type of
mission
somewhere in those procedures something
went wrong
and somebody in it outside ended up
outside that damn gondola
and then somebody else i think tried to
help rescue that dude i think that's
probably the most it was something like
that
uh yeah that the end result was is they
were both outside the gondola in the
damn water and they never made it back
you end up in the water at night
a lot of [ __ ] could happen to you sharks
it wasn't nighttime it was it was
daytime it was daytime it doesn't matter
sharks hypothermia currents and rip
tides
a lot of weird [ __ ] could happen and
maybe they weren't strong swimmers
we don't know but maybe you'll know more
about the case tell us more about the
case
all right so even though the sandwich
and coffee thing was not true
they did however find uh so it wasn't
true
i've said that like three times well i'm
kind of drunk man i'm drinking
he doesn't listen to this he definitely
can't he doesn't listen to her
i definitely could tell that they got
that from that ship story
yeah probably the sandwich thing yeah
but they did find one of the dudes hats
uh
just sitting on the flight controls like
just normal now interestingly
the radio was in perfect working order
which is very strange because
no one i mean if the radio had been
working and if something had gone wrong
for example one of the dudes had fallen
out of the gondola which
like i said is probably the most likely
thing that happened
um but why did they not call for help
they weren't that far off the coast
um why did they not answer any of the
radio calls that were sent to them i
mean because their last radio
transmission
was at 7 42 a.m right when they
were like hey there's an oil slick we're
gonna check it out and we just drop the
flares or whatever
louie is pointing out that i'm drinking
for two tonight
you got that right i'm drinking a little
bit too but i'm just i'm gonna stop
early yeah and yeah and he's gonna if he
makes another one he's gonna make it
super weak
or even don't even make an alcoholic one
maybe just like make something else
because like i said i want you want to
be uh sober
i want to be lucid for the next one so i
don't [ __ ] it up too much
the devil's going to be in the details
with this one yeah yeah so
so the radio was fine there was nothing
wrong with the radio again
very weird and i don't know why because
like i said their last radio trans
transmission was at 7 42 a.m and then
the the blimp
didn't come limping onto the shore until
like 11 15
you know what i'm saying so whatever
went on in there and like i said some
people saw the blimp
like right around nine in the morning
and it looked like it was still under
human power
and some people said that they still saw
the two guys in there at that point but
i don't know why they weren't answering
the radio
so um all right so they also
found when they inspected the gondola
they found all three of the parachutes
were still on board um which means like
i said that one guy that said he saw
somebody jump out in a parachute was
mistaken uh because all the parachutes
were there uh
the life raft was also still there um
obviously two of the smoke bombs were
missing but they
knew about that because they said hey
we're dropping the flares by the oil
slick so that wasn't
weird um there was also one of the dudes
had had a briefcase
that had like a lot of you know like
some classified information and [ __ ]
like that
that was still in its spot it was like
kind of bolted behind the pilot seat
nothing unusual there the engines
were completely fine the ignition
switches were on
the instruments and flight controls
operating normally
it still had four hours of gas in the
fuel tanks
and uh so it didn't look like anything
in particular had gone wrong with
the blimp itself um now
the the there were three life jackets on
there now two of them were missing
however
um if you're flying over water you
automatically were supposed to wear the
life jacket so they had life jackets so
they had life jackets on
um so they said so that wasn't that
wouldn't necessarily mean that they had
like jumped out and into the water
because you just had your life jacket on
sop standard operating yes so that
wouldn't make sense so you're in an
aircraft
over [ __ ] sea you better gonna have
your life jacket on because you're the
same as being in a boat
yeah it's an air ship that's what this
[ __ ] is
a zeppelin was an airship yeah so you
better have your life preserved wrong
yeah so so they were saying so that's
completely normal
um you know because they're gone and
obviously the two life things would be
gone
which meant that they went into the
drink with life preservers on
yeah because i know that's where they
went well yeah where else would they
have gone unless they got kidnapped by
aliens or something i don't if they had
come out over land then you'd have found
the bodies
yeah now there were a couple of
anomalies
um the one thing that was a little bit
weird was that the blimp's batteries
were drained
and that part of the fuel supply even
though there were still four hours of
fuel left
part of the fuel supply had been dumped
which was something that you would only
do
if you needed to increase your buoyancy
really quickly
so you like drop some ballast so you
drop some of your extra fuel
um so they it didn't really seem like
the blimp would have needed to do that
though so they weren't really sure why
the fuel had been dropped like that
what's that
hurricane tornado been getting tornado
warnings
yeah we've been getting tornadoes i
can't stop a [ __ ] tornado i don't
really need a warning what i'm going to
do is step i'm going to [ __ ] stop
this thing if it comes and gets us
it'll be recorded right here live on the
show
if a tornado comes and blows our asses
out of here that'd be exciting
at least you guys will know that a
warning was given give us a [ __ ]
tornado warning but i can't
that's the second one we've gone today i
don't really know what the what the
warning's for i can't stop it
well they're telling you to get your ass
like into your
shelter or get into the bathroom i know
this house very well a tornado would
[ __ ] cut through this house like
[ __ ] butter there is no safe
safety in this house zack says they have
tornadoes in florida oh yes
yeah all the time
hurricanes tornadoes anytime you have
like a big
thunderstorm which in the summer is
pretty much every day
uh usually has tornadoes coming along
with it
luckily they're not that big so use
you know i've never been through one but
knock wood but yeah so uh so again that
that was a little strange that the um
some of the fuel had been dumped
so um obviously the navy starts
looking everywhere for these two guys
because they got it what
they said fuel had been dumped did they
ever give you figures of how much fuel
was dumped
no there was four hours worth of fuel
left yeah so it wasn't that
like that they had dumped the whole
supply but they just dumped like i guess
the reserve that you would dump if you
needed like buoyancy quick
yeah i wonder if that's a mistake i
don't know
that was one of the feelings that was
one of the only unusual things that they
found
everything else was completely normal it
was functioning completely i'm gonna
[ __ ] go ahead and put a caveat
in here some people who might be really
into this case
maybe they're looking at that dumping of
the fuel and they've included that
in their hypothesis about what happened
be an ex-military i'm going to tell you
there could it could be
that whole fuel thing might be [ __ ]
it could be an
error it could be
that somebody in the ground crew [ __ ]
up and didn't
replenish the fuel enough or they
miscounted
or you know what i'm talking about they
could be that could be user error
because in the scenario i'm seeing
there's no time to dump any fuel
the evidence what the evidence is
showing me is that this is something
that happened
quickly it was unexpected because they
didn't call for help or anything like
that exactly you got it
which tells me there was no time to dump
any fuel
whatever fuel was missing it was because
it wasn't there in the first place
somebody forgot to do something
somewhere back back at the airfield
and what are you going to do rat on
yourself if that comes out in the
investigation he goes
oh no by the way no i forgot to refuel
the [ __ ] thing from the last mission
or you know what i mean yeah or i forgot
to refuel the [ __ ] reserve tank
they're not gonna rat on themselves so i
i
now you told me that and i'm already
[ __ ]
i'll smell a rat yeah i'm talking about
i don't think any [ __ ] fuel was
[ __ ]
i don't think any fuel was dumped i
think the fuel wasn't
properly monitored wasn't properly
recorded
back at base yeah maybe not although
like i said
it doesn't really that doesn't really
help when we were in the army we would
[ __ ] up constantly
just because something we would make a
claim doesn't mean necessarily
true i don't think any fuel was dumped
well i'm just saying what what the
that's what they're saying what
everything says
that's what they're saying and tom knows
better
well no i do know better because i know
i know that a lot of the [ __ ]
paperwork and [ __ ] from the just d
you're gonna have people in the comment
sections they're gonna agree with me
we used to fudge paperwork sometimes
when we [ __ ] up to try to hide it
hide mistakes that we made and stuff i
i think whatever happened it happened
quickly there wasn't any time for
remedial action or dumping any fuel
tanks
there was just something to happen just
because you would have made the call
back to report that there was a problem
yeah
long before you would have dumped fuel
tank just saying
it seemed to me very one of the weirdest
things about this is that there was such
a long
period of radio silence and when they
found the [ __ ]
and like i said witnesses reported
saying that
you know up to like an hour hour and 15
minutes after the last radio
transmission
it appeared that the ship was still
operating normally and was still on its
route and the guys were still in there
and stuff like that so why did they not
answer
their radio why did they not report
anything
why you know it's just like really
really weird dumping
fuel out of a tank out of an aircraft is
not an instant thing
it takes a long time you have to open
some valves and it's going to take
minutes for the [ __ ] fuel to come out
of there
you know what i mean the hole isn't that
big during that time you're gonna
[ __ ] call you're gonna say we're
having problems i'm dumping fuel blah
blah i'm trying to get
you're gonna be reporting back about
about the emergency
i just don't i just don't think any fuel
was dumped i think that the [ __ ]
fuel count was incorrect i'm imagining
that what really happened was
there's an emergency happened in this
damn zeppelin
that that happened and was resolved in
seconds
not minutes this is something that
happened in seconds go ahead
yeah it must have happened very quickly
i mean so there was no time to dump any
fuel
yeah so obviously the navy um
starts conducting a massive search
looking for these two guys
so they spent all night looking they had
[ __ ]
ships planes they had the coast guard
they had everything
and actually had really good weather for
the next couple days very calm very good
visibility
could not find hide nor hair of either
one of these dudes
so at this point both their wives are uh
you know informed
they're officially missing now
as far as like some of the [ __ ] about
what um may have happened to them so
some people have speculated that the oil
slick that they
were over that maybe that was a japanese
submarine
maybe they were um you know taken
prisoner
maybe this then the other thing although
a navy spokesman did say
that them being attacked by an enemy
submarine seems very unlikely
um nothing as i said nothing seemed to
be amiss with the blimp
and um it just it didn't really seem
like that's what was going on because
like i said a lot of witnesses saw
them over the area where this oil slick
was
and had there been a submarine there it
seems like it would have been
spotted or something unusual would have
been spotted no one really saw anything
unusual
they they just saw the blimp kind of
circling around about 30 50 feet up from
the water
and then you know for about an hour it's
like as though they were making sure
there was nothing there and then they
kind of just took off and went back on
their regular route so obviously they
didn't see a submarine
um so again you know the navy is even
saying that that's pretty unlikely that
they were like attacked by
an enemy um and pretty much i have to
say that yeah the navy is pretty much at
a loss they don't really know
um what happened to it they said there
was no
fire um you know obviously you know
there's no damage to the blimp it hadn't
gotten
wet um it didn't look like anybody done
anything incorrectly that they shouldn't
be doing
um it hadn't been hit by a missile it's
like you know it didn't look like
anybody had been
on there that wasn't supposed to be on
there no bullet holes yeah there was
nothing
um and nobody saw anyone fall out of the
cabin
at any point um you know no one all the
parachutes were there
how far away was that ship to uh to the
ball close enough that through
binoculars they could see the people
inside the gondola did they see them in
the gondola
when it left yeah what do you mean
yes yeah because what when the two ships
it was two ships it was a fishing
trawler and it was like another i don't
know it was like a navy ship or
something like that
and they were cl they were both close
enough that they could see the two guys
they uh they all reported like three
binoculars you could see the two guys in
the gondola
and they said we watched it we watched
the blimp circling around that one area
where this presumed oil slick was and
they said we watched it like kind of go
around this area for about an hour
and then it kind of took off back toward
like it was going back
on its route you know what i mean like
they thought it was just normal that's
because like i said they saw blimps
patrolling
yeah it was morning and when it left it
seemed to be under control
yes and nobody saw like i said nobody
saw anything
anybody fall out because everybody
presumes that at least one of the dudes
must have fallen out
yeah um and then the other guy had tried
to save it tried to save him and he fell
out too because
they said when they found the blimp
crashed
the little microphone that they used was
like outside
yeah as though he had been like calling
to somebody or something like that
my okay i'm gonna say that theory right
there checks out with everything that
i'm seeing and that's why they're saying
that
somehow during that observation
phase where they were circling around
looking for that damn
german u-boat submarine
the japanese yeah excuse me japanese
there were germans they were on the east
coast though yeah
uh that japanese [ __ ] submarine
during that phase somehow
something got compromised maybe that
dude opened that door to look out
and didn't reshut that door well enough
and then somehow later on he fell out
through that
through that open door or poorly latched
door
and maybe he was hanging on for dear
life and the other guy
reached over there and unbuckled his
[ __ ] and tried to pull him back in
yeah they got a hold of each other and
the guy fell and pulled the other dude
out with him
i think that's the most likely scenario
something like that obviously they
fell out at some point yeah they fell
out because they weren't in there
and you think well how do two of them
fall out very easy one guy comes out and
he's holding on somewhere
for dear life the other guy unbuckles
his [ __ ]
goes over there to try to help him try
to pull him back in they get a hold of
each other but the other guy falls and
pulls that guy out
yeah we don't know the weight difference
or the size difference the physical
and plus there's speed and maybe air air
speed and wind involved
too you know they both fall out
maybe the reason why having life
preservers on didn't make any difference
is because the
the height that they fell was very high
so they died when they hit the water
that's possible yeah they might have
been you know they might have been a
thousand feet off a [ __ ] ground off
the [ __ ] water when it happened
yeah but i have a feeling that during
that observation
phase they were trying to get a good
look
one of them was trying to get a good
look at the water
so maybe he opened the door to look out
and then when he re-latched the door to
leave he didn't latch it right
something like that now when it was
crashed they did find that it had been
latched
i guess you can latch it open yeah it
had been latched open
so they must been looking out yeah
they latched it open or they locked it
open yeah
and they were looking out
somehow they decided not to [ __ ]
close it
and guy ended up [ __ ] somehow in the
door frame
holding on for dear life the other guy
tried to save him they both went out
which like and he's it just makes the
most sense it's very weird to me that if
they were
suspicious enough about something to be
like looking out the door
yeah you'd think that they would radio
that's the weirdest things to me is that
the radio would be one thing if they
found the [ __ ] and the radio was broken
okay that would explain it
but it just seems very weird to me that
they wouldn't radio
past 7 42 a.m even though for like at
least an
hour afterward they were still moving
around like normal and they would but
they weren't reporting and they had to
know
i'd have to know all the details of how
they were trained
and what the procedures were what the
standard operating procedures were
did they go did they go into a [ __ ]
high
alert status and when you go into a high
alert status
their standard operating procedure was
to go into radio silence
did that happen you know what i mean
yeah could it be
that if you really suspected there was a
damn
submarine or a target down there were
you supposed to lock the door open
and when you locked the door open were
you supposed to be using other things
inside the damn gondola
you know like binoculars or
flares or what what else equipment was
up in there
that what that they were supposed to use
to try to [ __ ] idea target
you know i don't know all the little
details yeah the devil would be in the
details
some reason i mean they decided to
[ __ ] latch the door open
maybe they went into radio silence maybe
they got really focused in like we're
gonna get this [ __ ] sub we're gonna
come out of this [ __ ] heroes and
they're not really [ __ ] radio and
back they're not really thinking about
backup base they're trying to solve the
[ __ ]
problem at hand and then one of them
somehow slips and falls out
and he's holding on to the ledge and the
other guy says i'll get you
you know i mean they and they grab hold
of each other and the dude falls and
pulls the other guy out
it was something like that could have
been maybe they were just
[ __ ] proud [ __ ] that just you
know what i mean we don't know
the character of the crew maybe they
were just
real you know
what what do you call them [ __ ] real
confident
swaggering bad asses you know what i
mean ah [ __ ] base we're gonna take care
of this on our own
1930s style you know what i mean like
back in the flash gordon days
the character of the crew and the
standard operating procedures is where
you go
that's that's that's what will answer
this
yeah and they've done that yeah and then
you're done and i mean
these two guys like i said they had both
flown these types of craft before yeah
and
apparently they're never comfortable
with it yeah and it never gotten
into any trouble and you know so so
i don't think there was any reason to
think they may have broken some sop
young thomas maybe they were doing
something that wasn't quite
by the book it was something they were
used to doing
like hanging your ass outside the
goddamn gondola
you know what i mean and looking down
with a pair of binoculars
you know what i mean like a [ __ ]
on hrt you know you don't know
you don't know what they're thinking
yeah you weren't there
but it was something like that it was
something they must have been doing
something they weren't really supposed
to be doing but they did it anyway
like opening the damn door latching it
open hanging out looking with binoculars
and you know
doing real audie murphy [ __ ] like back
in the great war
i think it was something like that yeah
i mean there have been
um some other kind of uh theories as
well
that like i said you know some people
have said that they
were uh you know captured by a japanese
sub
no some people have said that they were
spies for japan
no um and that or that there was like
someone else who had stowed away
in the gondola and kind of overpowered
them
um some people have said that they maybe
wanted to go awol
um and you know [ __ ] it up somehow
um some people have even said that there
was like some kind of love triangle like
they were both after the same woman
someone murdered the other one and all
this other stuff
um rogue wave that's another one that
some people bring up
um and of course kidnapped by aliens no
that i know obviously that's not you
know
obviously that's not the right answer
it's going to be something that if you
saw it on the [ __ ]
if if it was something you saw on video
you'd go well of course that
of course it was something you know what
i mean it was so frustrating about these
is that it just seems like obviously
something happened
yeah this is kind of like i don't know
if you guys remember when we did that
show a long time ago about the horror
room 1046 or whatever
and it's like just all the details of
that are just so so weird
but if you knew what happened it
wouldn't be weird but that's why it's
weird because you don't know you don't
know
it was something like they weren't
following proper procedures
uh being a badasses and an accident
happened the other dude tried to save
the other guy
it was something that if you saw it
you'd go well of course
that's what it was it was something dumb
i mean like i said to me the most
mysterious thing is
the radio thing like why they didn't
keep everybody apprised
because it it happened fast the radio
was working
scott yeah okay yeah they said even
after it crashed the radio was in
perfect working order
and as i said oh my goodness you're
tearing [ __ ] up
oh i got she gave me that look she gave
you the look
yeah that angry look with her [ __ ]
eyebrows down
telling me to open to let her outside
put her little collar on
come on let's go see that that's it
[Laughter]
she's so cute yeah she comes in and she
gives him that
she's like i want to go outside i want
to go outside she wants to go out on the
back porch
but yeah so the weird i mean to me
that's the weirdest thing it's like why
okay if you thought that there was a
japanese sub there and then like you
checked it out and you didn't find
anything
and why didn't you like radio back and
go nah
it's good it was just an oil random oil
slick there's nothing there
we're gonna head on to wherever i'm not
really sure why they didn't do that
because it really does seem like
nobody fell out at that point i mean
nobody saw anybody fell out because at
that point when they were circling
around the oil slick
they were still being watched by like
the crews of a couple different
ships so i feel like if somebody had
fallen out
somebody would have seen that and
it and the fact that it circled around
the oil slick and then
just kind of kept on trucking like it's
in its normal route
you know obviously and the obvious two
guys were still obviously in there
so nobody fell out around the oil slick
time period
it had to have been some time later so
it's just it's very weird to me like why
why there was no radio contact like
within any of that time period
um now another another theory i'm pretty
sure i don't buy this one either but
there has been another theory kind of
floating around since 2009
that um that this blimp had like some
secret [ __ ] like some top secret [ __ ] on
it it was it
like not super top secret [ __ ] but it's
kind of like experimental radar
um and that something that was like
something
went wrong with uh some kind of
microwaves
on there and they fell out because of
that
um but you know like i said i'm not sure
that i'm not really sure that solves the
problem because obviously the two guys
fell out at some point for some reason
and they never did find them so
i don't know it's just really weird and
like i said the navy
has even come forward and said look
we've investigated this and we have no
[ __ ] idea like what happened to them
obviously they fell out at some point
but we
they never found them and they don't
know why they fell out and why
they weren't calling anybody on the
radio and they didn't call for help or
anything like that
so it's just a real weird case and like
i said it's
from in 1942 and they still don't know
what the hell ever happened
to those dudes um unless they got sucked
into another dimension
uh i'm you know you talking about flight
19 not yet
okay that'll that'll be the next thing
okay is she gonna be good
she's gonna be fine okay i told her to
keep that [ __ ] under control
keep that [ __ ] under control i had to
find her a collar
yeah she keeps losing those yeah i buy
those little like
from chewie i buy like a little bag and
it's got like six
little collars in there all different
colors they're all different colors and
they glow
yeah and they're break away so
she's just she's getting out there and
break them away yeah
she's like [ __ ] this yeah although she's
gotten better about that
we took a while she got rid of a couple
of the
of the ones like we found one out there
about a [ __ ] quarter mile away
found it with a flashlight at night yeah
she's like oh that's where that's that's
where that went
yeah oracle says pookie is an escape
artist yeah she is kinda
she's she's good though i mean she does
stay within
this area you know what i mean just like
right around
our house on the two neighbors houses on
either side they fell out of the damn
gobbler
at a high enough altitude to kill him on
impact that's what happened
then they were eaten by sharks yeah
probably that's what happened
um yeah some people have said too that
maybe the um
that the safety latch on the door wasn't
working right and maybe somebody like
accidentally leaned against it
and fell out or something like that but
you know like i said obviously
they fell out at some point yeah they
just never found them
that's shark territory and they got
they're floating on this their dead
bodies were floating on the surface with
the
life preservers and [ __ ] fish ate
them wouldn't take long
yeah that's true that's what happened to
them yeah depending on the currents they
[ __ ] went away from the coast instead
towards the coast
yeah they're just never found but uh
yeah so like i said after this uh
mysterious incident uh after world war
ii was over
uh goodyear did actually take this blint
back and fix it up
and uh they used it on all kind of like
sporting events and [ __ ] like that until
1982 yeah you probably saw it if you
grew up in the 70s and 80s
um and like i said i think it's in a
museum in pensacola now
so you see those things all the time
down in l.a they have patterns patterns
with the lights going on them look like
a damn
ufo they were cool yeah remember
but as a kid i had no idea how big they
were
they seem to be huge i thought they were
the size of the hindenburg no they're
not they're a lot smaller
yeah they're not individuals yeah a lot
smaller
size of maybe four or five train box
cars
that's about how big they are yeah but
um
so basically the two guys were declared
dead
uh a year after they disappeared and the
navy was basically just like
we have no idea what happened where they
went
sorry about that um they also did this
was on unsolved mysteries too i think
back in 1993.
yeah um so yeah now you want to talk
about
um somebody said alex rivera says a
[ __ ] alcohol was involved
not a joke possibly very possible at
that
in that era guys on duty [ __ ] in the
army drinking yeah
especially if they didn't have real good
supervision and
maybe they got alerted out and they were
kind of [ __ ] jumped
you know or they just said [ __ ] it they
just got drunk out there on those
[ __ ] missions and just threw the
bottles off
you know it's not it's not really that
it wouldn't have culturally been a very
big of a deal for them to do that
in uh back in the 40s it was um they did
leave very early on a sunday morning
maybe they were still hungover from
saturday nights
i actually think okay we're going to
talk about on flight 19. yeah
being hungover i think was a factor in
flight i think so too that might have
that taylor dude i think he might have
been having some issues
and um look man [ __ ] i loved
i loved close encounters of the third
kind and i knew about [ __ ] flight 19
i was a kid even when i was a kid
because i saw [ __ ] on in search of
yeah leonard nimoy his ass told me about
it
okay i hadn't grown up with [ __ ] you
know
in search of yeah
[Music]
that [ __ ] happened [ __ ] happened okay
so when i saw close encounters the third
kind
i really wanted it to be that it's like
yeah that's what happened to those dudes
but being older and understanding
[ __ ] the military
situation and having experience with
things like vertigo and
gray out and stuff you know which is a
weird [ __ ] thing that happened to me
on a causeway going out to new orleans
one time
gray car gray road gray water gray sky
boy i barely made it across that glam
[ __ ] causeway the only thing that
wasn't gray
with those [ __ ] dotted yellow lines
i thought i was [ __ ] spinning like
crazy
there's a bunch of [ __ ] that could have
happened to those dudes but we're going
to talk about it we're going to talk
about it i mean
the human brain it's pretty easy to fool
it yeah
if it doesn't have anything to latch on
to latch on to about where you are and
how fast you're going and
and what direction you're pointed in you
get get vertigo real quick
and you have to think too though like
back in the 1940s they didn't have like
all the really high tech [ __ ] we have
nowadays
no so well they were trained to fly by
instruments
yeah but i tried that too in that
situation and it's hard
yeah it's very hard because your head's
[ __ ] spinning
you're looking at the instruments but it
feels like you're just [ __ ] spinning
yep and then you uh time starts to
[ __ ] really stretch out you're not
really sure how long you've been doing
something
10 minutes or [ __ ] 10 hours and
we'll get into that case in a minute
yeah are we done with this case
yeah okay let's start about let's start
with so you're basically just saying
they were probably like hungover or
something like that and just kind of i
think it was a lot
it was a lot of things at once yeah but
i think being hungover was a factor
because i know that those dudes had
evidently been drinking the day before
and we're talking about a 1940s world
war ii drinking
okay and those dudes didn't weigh much
if you look at them if you look at
[ __ ] films of these guys
there were some spaghetti arm
[ __ ] it was a different era
okay people in general were just not
[ __ ] raised with on a high protein
diet it was a high carbohydrate [ __ ]
diet
and white men of the 40s were built like
children
they were unless you were [ __ ] an
athlete
look at world war ii they were a little
bitty skinny arms and
they would they drank a lot and i'm
telling you that [ __ ]
they didn't have much mass on them so
they couldn't have been resisting
alcohol that much yeah and they drink a
lot of it
this is confirmed yeah i had relatives
of that generation and they drank a lot
yeah and they drank it yeah it started
people think we drink a lot
no no no no
actually even when i was in the uk in
the 90s they just they could drink me at
the
table yeah i had a [ __ ] irish
girlfriend in boston and she could out
drink me
but i don't think she could have out out
drink out drank any of my uncles my
world war ii uncles
yeah no [ __ ] no they drink more than
russians
yeah that's saying something let's say
something they drink a fifth a day
see i can't even imagine that yeah they
drink a fifth a day and they'd be
[ __ ]
coherent see that's what kills me
yeah you know it's like i can't drink a
fifth
alcohol no me neither they sit down
fifth is [ __ ] scotch and still be
talking
i mean that that takes commitment
yeah and these are 150 pounds like years
and years yeah
doing that like every day yeah and these
were 150 pound dudes
yeah there was nothing to them you know
i mean you know
i i can i have a few drinks but after a
few drinks i started getting a little
bit incoherent you know what i mean
all you had to do was look at a 1950s
era say corvette
all right they were little a lot of
those cars from that time
the clothes from that time you could
tell how narrow in the shoulder they
were
they just were not massive guys
the whole fantasy of the cartoon fantasy
of superman and batman the way they drew
the drew those guys was just that it was
just
fantasy yeah very very few people were
actually built like that
and the first time you saw guys actually
built like that was the 70s during the
[ __ ] golden era
the golden age of bodybuilding and that
was because [ __ ] anavar
they were [ __ ] eating anapharm
working out
all right you had arnold and all these
guys and these [ __ ] back here
they were
they really started to become numerous
in the 70s well what kind of numbers
we're talking about
we're talking about under a couple
hundred under 100 yeah
in all of the united states so not
numerous at
all there are more dudes like that
right now than there have ever been that
weird
yeah i mean you know you there's all
this [ __ ] about all these soy boy
[ __ ] that are running around
like on how [ __ ] if
how feminine these new [ __ ]
young guys are today actually if you
actually look at the raw numbers and
what's happening
in the [ __ ] bodybuilding in the
health scene no
i don't think there's i don't think
we've actually
have been this physically fit ever no
of course not there's more of those
dudes than there has ever been well and
everyone is so much more aware
of and it's really easy to get healthy
food nowadays and get
supplements and get stuff like that they
didn't have that luxury back in
the world the difference is is uh back
in the 70s
action movies came out with those guys
and they were promoting it so everybody
saw it
now in movies and [ __ ] the media you
don't see that anymore
until you go on instagram you go on
instagram you will see how many of those
[ __ ] there are
there are dudes that are far bigger than
[ __ ] arnold or a dude that look like
arnold there's lots of those guys now
they're not even noticed at the gym now
there's lots of them yeah yeah this is
the trip they got girls
now that look better than any woman has
ever existed and
yeah they're on some of that [ __ ]
they're doing now back in the day they
did have muscle
women they didn't look good they got it
[ __ ] they got it worked out where they
still look female
yeah you know and that i like it it
looks good there's lots of them they're
all in their 20s 30s
42 but um
but yeah getting back to this [ __ ]
flight 19.
alcohol i think was involved in this
case but go ahead jim
all right so we're talking now about
another weird
disappearance this kind of uh
you know kind of cross-pollinates with
the whole bermuda triangle thing
like i said i'm pretty sure we never
talked about this before i don't i don't
know if we did a show about the bermuda
triangle i kind of feel like we didn't
we did we did some ghost ship shows we
did a ghost ship show i think
um and some alien [ __ ] but hold on i
gotta answer what
a question from tila tila says she's
quoting me they drank a lot back then
tom is that what jack nicholson meant
when the shining when he said white
man's burden
no that's not what he meant um
back i think this actually started in
the
50s and the 60s
there was a concept called the white
man's burden that would come up and that
was
um it was
it was kind of like a [ __ ] concept i
don't know
you could you can probably look more
into it you can re
you can research it online but from just
from memory
it was kind of like a [ __ ] cultural
phenomenon where
the white man was supposed to take the
loss
to help non-white people rise up to his
level
that was that's what that was talking
about the white house yeah it was a
little bit of a paternalistic
paternalistic realistic yeah
well we gonna have to um
[ __ ] give this up and then give this
up so
these not white people can catch up to
us yeah oracle points out white man's
burden dates back to kipling at least
he wrote a poem about it right you're
kipling yeah right they can't i thought
yeah i thought it was a pretty old
because i've seen because i've seen some
really old really really racist
uh sketches that we're talking about the
last time i ever heard
anybody see that [ __ ] was the 70s that's
just out of style as a [ __ ] yeah
so well the reason that it was british
it was a british thing
yeah the reason that he says that in the
movie i think is another thing
where they're talking about the genocide
the native american genocide
i think he's kind of getting that's why
he says that because he is talking about
and there's the whole thing too where
native americans are thoughts like the
oh they don't
um you know they're not as tolerant of
alcohol as white people
there's that whole thing too so i think
that's kind of what he was getting at
yeah a lot of that would
would have tied in with uh the stanley
kubrick style of shooting that movie
which of course is a [ __ ] masterpiece
of how the the overlook hotel was a
temple to evil
built by a bunch of rich [ __ ] evil
oligarchs really
built on the bones of their [ __ ]
enemies and it was decorated with the
[ __ ]
decor of their defeated enemies
basically indians and stuff that's so
what kind of
layered into that that
the oligarchy elites all saw this as
part of white man's burden
you know that's probably what they were
taught that's probably what kubrick was
talking about
yeah because i mean of all the theories
about the shining
probably about 80 of which i think are
probably [ __ ]
but the native american genocide thing i
totally do think that he was
well it was talked about in the book
yeah that
during the building of the of the
overlook they had to [ __ ] fend off
some indian attacks and they mentioned
that in the movie
they mentioned it in the movie allman
mentioned that would be the equivalent
of consecrating a [ __ ] ground
with spilt with a spilt blood like a
sacrifice
and you're consecrating the ground and
to me it was a temple
it was a temple to [ __ ] evil and
hedonism
that that was the idea yeah where elites
went to go play and party
commit crimes plan crimes all different
kinds of crimes like financial crimes
and stuff
crimes against mankind really and
to um revel in debauchery
and basically what what he's talking
about is epstein's island
it's like it was like epstein's island
place and it had a a spirit of its own
which was evil you know and it trapped
the ghosts of the evil
in it and that's why that [ __ ] movie
that's why that
that movie dr sleep i really appreciated
it the second time watching that
director's cut watching the direct cuts
on the second time i was like yeah okay
i see it now
because even the vampires appreciated
what it was
yeah and like i said that was one thing
that i did like about dr
sleep as opposed to you know you know as
a carry-on from the shining
was that the shining was kind of like a
place that
would kind of suck yeah the shine out of
people to power itself
and it was like a construct it was built
and it was built for that purpose
i think and basically they may be built
by accident
but what they did built that evil place
you know
and the true not in dr sleep were kind
of like
person equivalents of the overlook they
were like
psychic vampires yeah she was feeding
off
yeah rose the hat shows up and sees the
blood coming
coming out of the damn elevators and she
just [ __ ]
smiles and marvels at it goes yeah
yeah so she liked the place yeah she
knew exactly what it was
exactly what it was because she
recognized it she's like oh you do the
same thing that i do
except you're a building and i'm a
person right but you know it was kind of
the same thing
but um speaking of mike flanagan who
directed dr sleep
we might talk about oculus tomorrow
because mike flanagan also he says
awesome explanation tnj
okay yeah that's what it was yeah i mean
because there was so much native
american so i do think too that he was
trying to make
a kind of a microcosm macrocosm
type of thing of the genocide of the
native americans
and also the way that jack when he had
been taken over by the hotel
that he was subjugating his family
yeah too because because uh
wendy wears like kind of a lot of native
american looking
yeah clothes he's saying she's gonna
have to watch the movies again now so
she wants to see the shining again yeah
that's right
and you gotta understand all this [ __ ]
takes place
in the gold room and [ __ ] what you're
what i think what
what i think what
what uh what they're talking about the
gold room is kind of
kind of like the what they're talking
about the creation of the federal
reserve bank
it was a gold rum where the gold was so
you gotta remember when when when he got
when he first goes into the overlook
what's his name ullman
omen says only the best people stayed
here yeah
only the best yeah right only the best
sure only the best worst yeah
the best evil people yeah that's what
they're talking about you know the gold
room and they're in there [ __ ]
drinking and [ __ ]
and it's it's a temple built on [ __ ]
ground where they killed [ __ ] people
and [ __ ] those debauchery going on
murder in there and [ __ ] it's
decorated
in the motifs of your [ __ ] conquered
foes
that's what that's what that [ __ ] was
all about it's [ __ ]
witchcraft basically sorcery
rick shaw says didn't stephen king hate
the shining he did yeah yeah he did but
stephen king didn't understand the shiny
[ __ ] look at the television version
of
[ __ ] the shiny i like the television
version of shadow i did not
it's closer to the book it is but it's
far
inferior to the shape it's too literal
it is
yeah i think i've talked about this
before it's like it's not
awful but it's just it follows the book
very literally
and i think what kubrick did with it was
that he made it
mythic yeah it is the same story
yeah roughly kubrick's shining is the
exact same story
but that is the way um
his mom what was the mom's name um [ __ ]
wait who what are you talking about
danny's mom uh wendy winnie yeah
that was what it would have looked like
from wendy's point of view only
basically which is why i like it wendy
didn't see the ghosts until the very end
wendy didn't
all that other [ __ ] that happened in the
book wendy didn't know anything about
that
yeah so you're only seeing it from
wendy's point of view which is where
what it would have looked like from your
point of view had you been there
so it's still a masterpiece i give a
[ __ ] what you say
i just do and like i said i really think
i love the book i do
it's one of my easily one of my favorite
stephen king books it's a great book
but we've talked about this before um
you know
what works in a book and what works in a
movie are too complicated different
is very two completely different things
and the thing about it
is that one thing that when stephen king
made
the made for tv shining yeah um
he wanted to make it just like the book
which like i said fair enough it's his
book
he can do whatever he wants with it but
it just seemed to me
like it was too literal it was too
overexplained there was too much
exposition dump there was this whole
thing at the beginning where it's like
hey here's all the bad things that
happened at the
overlook and lit these are the ghosts
you'll be seeing later on it's like
it's so much creepier when you don't
know
when you when this you know this old
naked bag comes out of the [ __ ]
bathtub you don't know who's looking for
young boys and if you know the books
it's like you know what i mean so that's
like way way scarier because you're just
seeing this stuff without any context
you know you're seeing like a dude in a
[ __ ] bear suit like giving somebody a
[ __ ]
it's like you're just seeing that and
you have no idea like
what any of it and the overlook is just
this whole [ __ ] evil temple built
to serve and to create
and to [ __ ] store evil
old racist ghosts that's what they were
yeah
old racists ghosts yep i mean even
[ __ ] grady
remember that [ __ ] freely using the
n-word
that they were getting involved in this
yeah because that's not what the
overlook was
the overlook was the equivalent to
basically what you're talking about is
an aztec
sacrificial [ __ ] temple that's what
it was
but it was the white man's version of
that yeah yeah
and they're still running [ __ ] with the
federal reserve bank and all these
[ __ ] scams and banking scams and
buying up people's land and that's
that's what it is
alcohol orgies
[ __ ] dressing up in dog outfits and
dudes blowing each other that that's
what they're [ __ ] talking about and
that was only the best people
that was the best people yeah yeah yeah
see alex said exactly
it's too much telling instead of showing
yeah you can't tell like i said
that works in a book obviously because
you know all in a book all you have is
someone's words you're trying to build a
picture in someone's head
you know in a movie you have visuals you
don't have to do
ex exposition dumps you can just show
everything which is what you're supposed
to do
kubrick went back and just said well
what would this story look like just
from wendy's point of view
and that was the scariest [ __ ] point
of view because she didn't have all the
details
and yeah she just had no [ __ ] idea
what was going on yeah a couple [ __ ] got
added you know what i mean there wasn't
uh
a maze instead there were hedge animals
they didn't have the technology to do
the hedge animals the way they were
described in the maze was so much better
right the man because then you have that
theseus and the minotaur thing and
halloran lived in the book
yeah uh but in the movie somebody had to
die
or it wouldn't have been a horror movie
if halloran didn't die then nobody died
what kind of horror movie is that
so they killed hollering in it which
when i was a kid that scared the [ __ ]
out of me
i think that was the scariest thing the
bathtub scene and halloran getting
killed
that used to really really upset me when
i was a kid
because he was such a likable character
and he spent
half the movie trying to get up there to
save danny and then
the problems between the book and the
movie and then i think it was all worked
out with the director's cut of
dr sleep it all kind of i think it all
started to fit
back in together when they did the
director's cut of dr
sleep they purposely did what they could
to
link the book and the movie together and
it and then it made sense it made a lot
more
yeah it was a lot better scott said the
hedge animals were sort of dumb in my
opinion
i do like in the book they were creepy
but it would only work in a book it yeah
it only works in a book
because i mean obviously when they did
the cgi hedge animals in stephen king's
version
it was just the silliest looking thing
it was like not scary at all
i mean a maze is so much scarier
obviously rick the tv
version is i like it
but i don't like it as much as the
[ __ ] kubrick's version but i do like
it
um it is verbatim what the book was
yeah it's pretty much exactly like the
book uh the thing is is that the tone
is kind of in some ways a little bit
goofy
because what works in a book doesn't
work in a movie very well it doesn't
even work in a television series very
well plus the makeup on the ghost
was just really not i think it was
creepier in kubrick's version because
the ghosts didn't i mean other than
the the rotted lady in the bathtub who
was horrifying but other than that like
most of the ghosts just looked like
normal people they were just people that
weren't supposed to be there
and like that was way scarier to me i
mean
because you know you have somebody turn
up with like kind of gray like halloween
looking makeup it's like
yeah yeah it's not really all that scary
you know i don't think i've listened to
all the comments go ahead and read
you the proof is in danny sweater he's
talking about the [ __ ] uh yeah
i lo i honestly love all the stuff in
there about the weird
geography of the hotel you know what i
mean like all the [ __ ] that they
shot with like danny and it's like no
he's facing this way on the carpet and
now look the carpet pattern is reversed
and all the i mean just the fact that he
thought of all that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] crazy michael says i'm glad i
haven't watched it then thanks tom i
don't know what he's talking about
unless you're talking about the
television series of the shiny i don't
know
michael i don't really know what you're
talking about what you haven't watched
the the television version the
television
mini series of the shining is worth
seeing it's worth seeing
um but you you don't want to put that
above the kubrick movie
and i didn't like even though like you
said this was
exactly like the book even though in the
tv version
um tony was
a teenage boy that like kind of floated
around
yeah and talked to danny which
to me i know that's how it was in the
book yes it's an older version of him
and all that other stuff
i know they went into that in the novel
but to me it was just
super super cheesy it's just it seems
like so danny comes outside
you know with his teeth that because
that poor little kid had that
had that teeth thing that really like
distracted me but um
and he sees like a kid like a teenage
kid with glasses like floating by the
stop sign like telling him [ __ ]
just that's just not scary to me it's
not scary it's just cheesy that's the
way it was in the book though
i know but it's not but it just goes to
show
i mean it's just kubrick's version just
him like talking in that weird voice
that's like
way creepier kubrick understood that
less is more
yeah um now someone's talking about
blowing the dogs no that's not what
happened
in the kubrick's version of the movie
you will see a guy in a dog costume with
the [ __ ]
with the ass open on the costume
some dude who was in a tuxedo in a
tuxedo
now in the book what this is about there
were these two
tycoons one of them was this i think
this took place
back in the 30s zach is asking me who
are the actors in the tv version
it was um the dude from wings the [ __ ]
was that dude's name
and i think rebecca de mourney played
wendy
what the [ __ ] was that dude's name from
wings somebody'll know
it's that dude he plays jack i'm trying
to answer the question back in the 20s
according to the [ __ ] book there were
these two
tycoons and one of them
he was bisexual he would [ __ ] with a
dude but only once
not twice once his curiosity was
satisfied he wouldn't do it again
but the other tycoon was gay and in love
with the dude
he wanted to [ __ ] get a piece of that
[ __ ] on a regular basis
dude was kept telling him no he wasn't
going to [ __ ] go back for seconds
finally he goes okay i'll let you i'll
let you [ __ ] blow me and do some [ __ ]
to me again
if you dress up in a dog costume and the
guy was like
he's like okay and dude did it somehow
those those dudes ended up dying later
on and their ghosts got [ __ ]
absorbed into the [ __ ] in into the uh
into the overlook because the overlook
hotel of course captured ghosts that's
what it did
it was this is like an evil place
stephen weber thank you
who's stephen weber the guy that played
jack in the tv version yeah that's right
i couldn't remember his name i was just
like the guy from wings the guy from
wings
the tv version of it could be redone
into a bigger more expanded version of
the [ __ ]
uh uh of the shining you could remake
that
and do it a lot better with a lot better
tone you could
with today's with today's technology i
mean i wrote a blog post about it where
i compared the two things
um and i was kind of [ __ ] on the tv
version a little bit but
i'm like look i'm not saying that there
can't be
a really really good version of the
shining that's really close to the book
you know i mean they could make a really
good movie version of the shining that's
close to the book
but that ain't it that's all i'm saying
and zach's gay ass jumps in here goes
wait who's gay
zach if you didn't hear the [ __ ]
story i'm not going to tell it again
that see i know you know what it is zach
just wants me to [ __ ]
tell him gay stories that's what it is i
hear the gay story yeah
zach wants to hear gay stories told in
my voice that my [ __ ] loves me
[ __ ] [ __ ] you love me zach yeah you
you should just do a whole you should do
a whole [ __ ] gay podcast for you
yeah there you go yeah steven weber died
holy [ __ ]
in 2007. he wasn't that old was he i
don't know [ __ ] man the tv
sorry stephen yeah don't haunt me but um
he was a fine actor i'm just it wasn't
his fault
um you know that that the tv version
wasn't that good
michael got him though michael goes the
dude dressed up as the [ __ ] dog
blowing the guy what was
that zach
yeah mark navarro just out of nowhere
said [ __ ] meat sandwich
yeah so you know
rick's going gay can't fire tara
zack says tom know you're my dad's age
i'm not into that kind of thing
this [ __ ] has always kind of come on
come on how old i am he's my dad's age
[ __ ] man [ __ ] all that [ __ ] oh you're
making you're making time
no not your dad's age you probably are
though
because zack's only like 23. oh that's
right everybody he's a baby
yeah yeah [ __ ] keeps messaging me
oh okay tammy says okay oh stephen
webber isn't dead he's still alive okay
he's been on ncis new orleans okay never
mind so he can't haunt me not yet
[Laughter]
he might haunt me later though
so you want to talk about you want to
talk about flight 19 uh let me go get
another
drink you want a drink um i'll make it a
real week one a super super week
i mean i still have like three hours
before i have to go on the other show
so i have time to i have time to process
it all out
but we'll see how it goes but yeah so
we gotta talk about flight 19 but i
really want him to be back here for this
it's like see every time we start
talking about the shining and it's like
i just never stop
talking i just never want to stop
talking about it because it's just
a fascinating topic like i said every
now and then i'll i'll kind of go on
youtube and just like watch
because there's 50 bajillion videos on
there like with different theories and
all this other kind of stuff
and even the people that have like
crackpot theories and [ __ ] i'll listen
to that [ __ ] too i don't even care
um even though i'm just like watching it
going you are so high right now
but that's what's so awesome about that
[ __ ] movie is that
even [ __ ] like that sounds like it could
be kind of plausible
you know so that's all one of these days
i mean probably not soon because we just
watched dr sleep and like i said it's
like [ __ ] three hours long
um one of these days i kind of want to
watch the shining and then dr sleep like
one after the other i'll just you know
just get all comfortable and get a bunch
of snacks and
[ __ ] like that and then we'll just like
sit through like [ __ ]
six hours of the movies or however
[ __ ] long it is that sounds like
super fun
but uh yeah so taylor said sorry to
bring it up
no that's okay um like i said i could
talk about the shining all [ __ ] day
long man
and i i you know i've written a bunch of
stuff
about it like on my blog [ __ ] where i
compared it to the book
and compared it to the tv version to the
kubrick version
and all this other kind of stuff it's
just it's an endlessly fascinating
uh it's an endlessly fascinating thing
uh thank you very much
is it is it uh really weak yeah well
hurry up so we can start talking about
flight 19.
hurry up
[Music]
i still have three hours for the other
show so i'm hoping that
we'll uh then i'm hoping i'm i'm not
gonna get too messed up
today tila said you're watching both of
them tonight
zach says i still say hereditary is
scarier now that movie
seriously one of these days god i'm just
so tempted because
i saw it in the theater when it came out
in 2018 and
that movie and you guys know i'm
you know i'm super into horror movies
and i always want to see something that
like traumatizes me i know that's weird
to say
but i very very rarely see anything that
really bothers me or like gives me
nightmares
that [ __ ] did oh my god that movie
scared the [ __ ] out of me
and it scared me so bad that it's like
like i said i really want to watch it
again because
as i mentioned there's so much stuff in
there
that i missed and i really want to go
back and
watch it so i can catch everything but
every time i think about re-watching it
i just i get anxiety
so i just i haven't rewatched it like
for two years
like i'll watch videos about it like and
they're pointing out like look at all
the hidden ghosts and look at all this
stuff that was going on in the
background that you didn't notice and
look at all this symbolism and stuff
so i'll watch that but and i'm sitting
there going man i really need to sit and
watch that movie again and it's just
like i just can't i can't
i don't it's so strange because
it was one of those movies that it just
made me feel
so bad like for
like maybe two weeks after i saw it it
just made me feel
shitty but also awesome because
a movie hadn't done that to me for a
really really long time and it was like
and it was really
like a like revelatory because i was
like oh my god a horror movie hasn't
like stressed me out and made me feel
this crappy for like such a long time so
i was like hooray
so i was like really happy about it but
then on the other hand i was like but i
still feel
really shitty and freaked out and it's
like giving me nightmares and stuff
so it's like it was a really weird
experience
and it's like i don't know i'll watch it
again one of these days when i
when i get my uh my bravery back but as
it is now it's just like every time i
see it i see the cover coming up and
going
oh am i ready to feel like that again i
just i don't know i don't know
i don't know but i don't know i'll i'll
get around to it one of these days
cujo in the original elm street scared
me um
i remember the first nightmare on home
street's kind of creeping me out so it's
like even there's even a couple scenes
in there
in the original nightmare and i'm
straight that still kind of creep me out
the one scene that really creeps me out
is when nancy is in the classroom
and the guy is reading what the [ __ ]
he reading from it's like he's reading
from shakespeare i think
and he suddenly starts like she falls
asleep but they don't but you don't know
that
and then um the guy reading suddenly
starts reading and he's like
like like that like in a whisper and
then she sees
tina like in the body bag like in the
hall and there's like i don't know that
like weirds me out of that scene
still like that well look at you you
just kind of like took off and
you ate that whole big thing at red
lobster and now you're still hungry
it's protein i can't okay i told him i
was like look i have like leftover food
from there i can't even eat it till
tomorrow afternoon because i'm just like
my stomach is soft cause i'm a [ __ ]
man
i know you're gonna eat what we're gonna
eat you know we get
we get hungry it's protein though
you don't gain fat from that yeah that
makes sense and muscle
okay yeah that's good
all right cured ham yeah
where did that ham even come from did
you you made it yesterday
i bought it during the um
yeah i made it yesterday but remember i
bought that ham during last holiday
season i froze it
oh okay i didn't know spiral cut hair i
don't even know what the hell is in the
freezer
because you don't look well i don't ever
have any reason to go in there
i glaze that [ __ ] in everything it's a
spiral cut ham that's a bunch of it
we have the ice maker on the outside of
the door and that's the only thing i
ever get is ice water
so it's like i'm not so it's not like
i'm just digging around in the freezer
for anything
anytime you need a sandwich just pull
off slices of that spiral cup
okay well like i said i i got my lunch
tomorrow covered because i still got
like half that meal from red lobster
left whatever
so i gotta i got a bunch of like coconut
shrimp because coconut shrimp like i
said is my favorite i didn't realize
they were gonna give me so many of them
like on this platter like in addition to
all the other things
i thought it was just gonna be like a
little bit like oh it's a little piece
of fish it's a couple scallops it's
no it wasn't it was like this big huge
baked potato
it was like all these shrimp it was like
really big ones and then it was like
this whole big
thing of scallops and like two big
things if i'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] man
i didn't realize it was gonna be this
much food
it wasn't that much that expensive i'm
going back over all the comments
yeah yeah michael shaffer says jenny you
better hurry up or tom is going to eat
your leftovers you better not eat my
coffee
at [ __ ] i'm going to punch you
right in the face i got several pounds
of [ __ ] frozen
shrimp that ready to cook it's been in
there for months see i didn't know that
was in there either no we're gonna have
we can have shrimp boil whenever you're
ready
yeah yeah i got i got saturn's [ __ ]
shrimp seasoning and everything
one of these days we're gonna have to do
like a shrimp boil yeah put some corn
and potatoes in there
yeah dump it all out on a table with a
plastic bag on it
i just go to town i'm over here [ __ ]
tripping and tila didn't know what white
man's burden was and didn't get didn't
catch the whole fact
that that that the overlook hotel
was a temple to old racist white white
ghosts that's what it was what it was
old racist old racist white ghosts that
were pretty much
that ran ran the world
rich [ __ ] oracle's asking when
the cookbook is coming out
that it's still yeah you really need to
you i was
i've been trying to get you to work on
it i'm up to a point now
where like almost all of the american
section is done and then there's like a
couple of other like
little sections that i need to get
through but i need you to come in and
consult
yeah on it before i finalize all the
[ __ ] she jumps in saying she just saw a
predator
really in 2019
hold on prior to 2019 we come up
prior to 2019 i don't know that one
she's talking about predators
maybe okay we saw that in the theater
didn't we yeah predators was in 2019.
it was it was that right yeah i liked it
i think that was more like 2014 what
2012.
no it wasn't that long ago we saw that
on the amc thing didn't we oh
that one that one yeah yeah yeah that
was that wasn't bad
it wasn't bad but it wasn't great either
well i mean you know
i was i was expecting it to suck so it
was like it was a nice surprise it
wasn't as good as uh
predators that's true i liked predators
better i did too
yeah zack said i don't think i've ever
had shrimp boil oh god that sounds good
god damn it it is yeah man oh when you
can do you can do shrimp
where's this [ __ ] from where are you
from zach you can put shrimp in there
you can put uh
crawfish in there you can put whole
whole blue crabs in there
yeah and then you put in potatoes and
corn you know corn on the cob throw in
some
uh cajun seasoning put a whole cloves of
garlic in there half
lemons lemons onions yeah you can put
all kind of stuff in there
he just said boil it in a big-ass pot
yeah big pot big big ten gallon pot
and then you just dump it all out just
most people like we'll put we'll cover
like a picnic table with uh
newspaper like outside and then you just
kind of dump it all out open garbage
bags
yeah that's what we did though we cut
out some garbage bags and put them on
the table and just dumped everything out
you just reached over and grabbed
potatoes
and then just eat it thrown a [ __ ] over
your shoulder
i know that's what i said i said you
just eat it with your hands like a
savage
it's super super good though yeah
although i like a little bit of
i like a little bit of finesse because i
do like to put like some butter and [ __ ]
like that on the corn
but uh yeah so um
are you are you ready to talk about
flight 19 now yeah are you sure you're
talking about predator but
okay go ahead well you can talk about
predator a little bit if you want to i
can't believe it i still got you i just
saw
predator one and two recently no [ __ ]
predator one is a [ __ ] masterpiece
man that's a masterpiece
one of the greatest movies of all times
if you say what's the best movie
for me predator predator one not back to
the future
no back to the future is is a perfect
movie but it's not the best movie
for me personally it's real close
between predator one and terminator one
and just you know and that's it i didn't
like terminator 2 that much i didn't
like it
none of the other term just terminator
one because it was it was a simple
horror movie
terminator one predator one that's it
now predator 2 that's good
predators better uh the predator
2009 uh 2019
it it had mo it had
moments where it could be it could have
been great the edit wasn't right there
was a lot of stuff that was wrong with
it
just i would have edited a lot of that
out
yeah the whole thing about the [ __ ]
predator
was not knowing what the goddamn
predator looked like that was really
what it was all about
well yeah and once you've blown that
watch you can't really
make another like the sequel is not
going to be it's everything like you've
seen
right and it only worked for that time
period because most most aliens
creatures the special effects they
didn't look realistic with the exception
of alien one and two
look they looked pretty good when that
predator took its mask off
when i saw it brand new in the theater
man the entire theater just gasped
because we didn't i mean that makeup
still looks kick-ass we didn't know that
was possible
and then all of a sudden when i i was in
okay i was enjoying the movies the first
time i ever saw it i was in brazil at
the time as a kid
everybody was loving the [ __ ] movie i
wasn't really sure what i was dealing
with though
until the mask came off the predator and
i saw its face
and everybody gasped and i realized i'm
watching the probably one of the best
movies ever made
i said this is this is a [ __ ]
masterpiece
and then the way it ended and i was just
afterwards i was just like
god and it was
it was it was it kind of was weird
because it was the 80s and it
and and i was young it was almost normal
to see this amount of greatness
happening on the on the silver screen
i was getting spoiled you know
and it did happen a couple times after
that but it never really
was able to top those movies from the
80s and some of them from the 90s you
know i mean like robocop won
also a [ __ ] masterpiece and it has to
do with
you know how i guess i guess it has to
do with how jaded the [ __ ]
the audiences are now you can show
anybody anything
imagery is just easy you can do any kind
of imagery you want
so it's not as impressive it was always
in the context of the time
yeah you know but uh
no in the context of the time the best
movie experience ever
ah [ __ ] it's hard to say it would have
been
predator one terminator one
alien one and two and blade runner
that those were kind of like the coolest
things you'd ever saw on
on film how about the thing oh yeah that
one too
that one too i mean that [ __ ] blew my
mind when i thought right
and all the special effects and all of
the back to the futures
had a feeling of perfection to them
especially especially part one
it just feel it felt really good to
watch those um
now there was a bunch of other movies
they weren't perfect but they were
[ __ ] great you know what i mean like
the beverly hills cop one and two three
not so much but one and two were really
good
um a lot of the eddie murphy movies i
[ __ ]
i was right there for them it was at the
right time the right place as the right
it was
it was the right generation for them um
there was
just there was a lot of good [ __ ] out
back in those days
but a lot of it i think had to do with
the audiences
yeah yeah i mean i mean people are
really yeah people are really spoiled
for choice nowadays
i mean the thing about it is that
there's so many which in a way is good
like that there's
that the cost of making things has come
down so much that
you know there's so many good indie
movies nowadays so you can pretty much
just
you could spend the rest of your life
just watching
you know uh particular movies that are
kind of geared toward your particular
tastes
and you would never run out of [ __ ] you
know what i mean like as far as series
and
i mean because i sometimes i look at
because i kind of keep a running tally
of just horror movies and series that i
want to watch
and i will never live long enough to get
through all of them never
because there's still like a lot of
classic [ __ ] i haven't seen yet too and
i trust so i try to keep up on that
and then i try to keep up on like horror
fiction and [ __ ] like that there's just
no way that one person
but you know and it sounds like i'm
complaining but i'm not but i mean
there's just like so much good [ __ ] out
there
nowadays that in a way it's harder
because you have to like go through a
lot of crap
to find a good [ __ ] but there's just so
much
content out there that you would just
never get to the end of it
you know what i mean yeah there's all
kinds of cool comments in there
yeah louie 48 hours was good too so was
the sequel
that was also good um
they were trying to be kind of like
hard-boiled [ __ ] cop flicks
with eddie murphy is kind of lightening
it up they were never
good also like i said i like [ __ ]
golden child too that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
crazy
there's all kinds of crazy [ __ ] that was
happening somebody else was saying that
i don't forget who was um that robocop
was
for satire yeah it was for satire but it
didn't matter yeah it was all just good
you know what i mean the the tone was
right for the time
yeah you laughed at it but you know it's
just the way it was
even some of the most of the ed most of
the um
most of the the arnold schwarzenegger
movies were low budget
but it didn't matter they were [ __ ]
great you know uh when you were a kid
watching them
in your teens
i mean sometimes even early twenties you
know what i mean you're [ __ ] watching
uh [ __ ] [ __ ] running man and uh what
was the worry goes to mars [ __ ] total
recall
they were they were masterpieces of
their time
not as much as a masterpiece as co as
conan though you know [ __ ] conan the
barbarian the first one was a
masterpiece the second one
uh not so much but the first one was
which was really sad the second one
could have been really good but
yeah they just they cheaped out on it
they wanted to dumb it down to a pg
movie to try to get more kids to see it
yeah and they had they wanted to dumb it
down and make it more
friendly because uh dido de laurentiis
[ __ ] studios was
had really overspent and really [ __ ]
up its budget
especially with [ __ ] like dune and
[ __ ] flash gordon they spent too much
goddamn money on them so
they tried to make cash grab low budget
movies that were passable
you know towards that period i was
another one man [ __ ]
i loved [ __ ] the original flash
gordon i just thought that [ __ ] was sexy
as [ __ ] it was sexy star wars i had
drugs in it and sex in it and [ __ ] a
hot [ __ ] princess aura and [ __ ] like
that
i i have to say i loved all the costumes
and the set design and that
the costumes were super expensive and
they blew so much money on them and
same with the [ __ ] the old dune the
new dunes coming but
we'll see uh the old dune [ __ ] was a
trip
too it was just it was another time it
was another time i told him yesterday i
was uh
i went to visit my sister my brother and
i was in
downtown orlando and there's a place
there called park avenue cds which has
all like old vinyl and it has like all
kind of books and toys and it's like a
really cool place
and um i was in there and i said i told
him i said i saw a vinyl pop figure
of paula treitis from the original dune
the david lynch one and it was super
cute i almost bought it from you
but i was just like well maybe not but
they had a lot of cool ones and that was
that was my favorite one
that stuck out so many so many good
movies being mentioned you know down the
comment
tremors and oh yeah i know man i love
tremors
near dark we really need to do a
retrospective on that have you ever seen
it i've never just seen it
oh it's good it's vampire but it has
like a western
kind of you know maybe i haven't seen it
catherine bigelow directed it she's like
won an oscar later leave the weapon and
die hard that's right louie
leave the weapon and die hard we're
[ __ ] great now you [ __ ]
gonna get me talking about that
die hard one die hard 1 was the [ __ ]
masterpiece die hard 2 was pretty good
the rest of them now lethal weapon
i have them all they're not it's it's a
it's a good series what i liked about
lethal weapon
all in all when the [ __ ] all the
movies were done it was a
it was a series it was about friendship
it was all about
friendship between dudes no matter what
their imperfections were
so it was they were good movies all of
them although the
out of them all the first and the second
one were the [ __ ] best you know
just it's hard to do movie three and
four you know what i mean
and pretty much any franchise is going
to run out of gas right around that time
period because
like i said when everybody sees the
first movie everybody's like whoa this
is like something new and cool
look at this character and we love this
and then the second one people are like
okay yay this is just still the same
people and what and then by the third
one it's like all right we're sick of
this [ __ ] now the only series that
didn't run out of gas was phantasm
fantastic phantasm got stronger as it
went
i like all the fantasies yeah which is
very strange i've watched all of them
longer as it went
i really i mean they all have red they
all had reg and i [ __ ] love reg
well that was a labor of love
where it was a guy who was making a
movie that he was starring in and he was
creating his own
cinematic universe i mean i love how
weird this [ __ ] is i just love [ __ ]
weird yeah
um somebody said we should do a we
should do a retrospective on silent rage
which that's actually that's pretty much
the only chuck norris movie that i like
because it's like a horror movie like
it's a serial killer movie essentially
um so yeah i might actually that i might
do that at some point
um zach was saying one of his favorite
movies is klute
with uh jane fonda and donald sutherland
was in that i think i saw that a long
time ago i remember liking it a lot i
saw it on cable back in the day
zach said james bond is still going
strong yeah that's true
that's true too but you know that's been
going on for a long time and
the the stars have changed it's been
rebooted many times
well the thing about james bond is that
it's not i mean it is a continuing story
but
he's just like a recurring character
that you can put in all kinds of
different situations it's been rebooted
many times
yeah you know um really um
one of the one of the best james bonds
was living daylights and that had
that guy was only he was only in one of
those what was his name um that wasn't
that wasn't timothy dalton was it yeah i
think it was timothy dalton
it was timothy dalton and he was only in
living daylights and and that was a good
one
that's right he was only in one wasn't
one who was the other dude
that was in um after that it was like
tomorrow night
what's the [ __ ] yeah where's the
other guy [ __ ] man now i can't remember
somebody he was good too but uh there
was something about timothy dalton
timothy dalton
had kind of a little bit of a of a
harder edge to him
and he was kind of like um the guy they
got now what's his name [ __ ] um
who's james bond now daniel craig daniel
craig he was kind of like the first
first version of a daniel craig type
dave james bond which was supposed to be
closer to the book
to the books yeah so louis said there
were two timothy dalton ones because he
was also in license to kill oh was he
okay that's what oracle said
yeah uh teal asked if i had seen 10 to
midnight the serial killer movie with
charles bronson yes i have
but it was a very long time ago i
remember like really liking it but
i got to get those timothy dalton ones i
don't have them yeah
i got to get them i i saw the very first
one
timothy dalton one and i i saw it in
brazil when i was a kid and i [ __ ]
i loved i liked it but i had to see it
again i don't know how it i don't i
don't remember how it aged i don't know
how it's aged
i remember it being kind of hardcore
compared to the say
the roger moore um because i was coming
out of the roger moore era which i liked
those two but they were
they're a little silly they were kind of
almost like star wars movies yeah
you know what i mean where was big and
crazy you know
and you know dude comes out of [ __ ]
scuba diving from a sewer and he comes
out
in a [ __ ] tuxedo and can walk right
in and play [ __ ] you know what i mean
playing at the [ __ ] casino and [ __ ]
nobody smells him i mean it wasn't
realistic at all
yeah but it was just it was james bond
you know well yeah
zoran industries and [ __ ] you know
what i mean you had [ __ ] all
what's the name [ __ ] uh [ __ ] what was
her name
black black chick [ __ ] rock star um
grace jones grace jones yeah
grace's skinny ass she'd be [ __ ]
running around like an assassin
of jumping off the top of the eiffel
tower it was crazy you know what i mean
duran duran was there watching and
everything
this [ __ ] old bond was [ __ ] i love
that song i have to say yeah
i mean i love duran duran roger moore
trying to be sexy as [ __ ] at 60
in this [ __ ]
chasing to 23 year old girls you know
what i mean it's just like
unrealistic that's pretty common in
movies of that type of unrealistic issue
it's like this old grandpa old grandpa
running like running after like this 23
year old woman
nothing ever happened that normally like
in real life she'd be like
yeah yeah you're like my grandpa's age
that's super gross
that was [ __ ] james bond that was
fantasy yeah
what my fantasy it was somebody else's
fantasy that's like the that's like the
old
the dads that are watching yeah they
look like their fantasy i could totally
score a 23 year old like
young girl sure yeah so i was i was a
[ __ ] teenager watching it chirping
out on it you know
look at this yeah does that actually
happen you know
no no that's your answer right now no no
all right so uh can we talk about flight
19 yeah are you sure about flattening
are you sure you can talk about it
because as soon as i start talking about
it i'm going to start talking about
something looks like the audience is
ready for it everybody's going good got
it
got people in there i still got time
it's only 7 21. okay good
so i still got i still got a while
before i have to do the other show
and this is the last drink that i'm
having and it's a week one so
i'll have time to chill out in between
um all right so we're talking about the
mysterious disappearance
of flight 19. this was probably also on
unsolved mysteries maybe
hold on one second i knew it i knew it
sheila says timothy dalton wasn't so
good looking other people are going well
he wasn't
most people thinking he was in two of
them i thought he was in one timothy
dalton wasn't good looking because james
bond wasn't supposed to be good looking
he wasn't that good looking according to
the books
but i don't think i've read any of the
james bond i mean i feel like i
i feel like i i probably did at some
point but
maybe it didn't really make much of an
impact no he was supposed to [ __ ]
be all beat up looking and he was drunk
most of the time they were pulling him
out of the damn gutter
[ __ ] and sobered him up to go on
these missions all the time he was beat
up
[ __ ] so i i actually i actually think
daniel craig
is is the closest to where he was
described in the book with david craig
i'll that's my favorite james bond just
saying sorry people
probably mine too i guess dan craig is
my favorite i mean sean connery is good
too but
those are those are so dated that and
daniel gray's getting a little too old
for the role i i want to see the new
movie coming out but i don't i haven't
really heard good things about it
the the three or four that are early out
the last one spectre i liked it
but that was a good time to end that
that him being bond i think
he's just getting a little long in the
tooth he is supposed to be
kind of older but it comes to a point to
where you know what i mean you go like
dude
you're not in shape enough to do what
they're showing you doing you know what
i mean
when he first started he was doing
parkour and [ __ ] and [ __ ] running
around jumping chasing dudes down
t if you haven't seen the tila if you
haven't seen the [ __ ]
the daniel craig james bonds check them
out
especially casino royale the first one
that was my favorite one
the second one i think skyfall was my
favorite skyfall was really good of the
daniels i liked them all
i liked them all i liked i liked them
all um
some people said well quantum of sauce
wasn't that good i like squadron
solace i liked it too but i think it was
the weakest one it was the weakest one
but i still liked it it had paranormal
references
about guys hearing the [ __ ] voices of
their mother
warning them about the drought weird
[ __ ] was happening
there was um some [ __ ] there's a lot of
[ __ ] that's kind of true
showing the elites in an opera talking
to each other with a big eye of sauron
and how they were [ __ ] forming
spectre it was just
basically just a cabal of rich people
who were [ __ ]
using the world's governments and they
had bought up the world's governments so
they could run [ __ ]
organized crime like child trafficking
and human trafficking and using [ __ ]
big
tech to [ __ ] spy on people it was all
all that [ __ ] was like
like yeah it sounds like what you got
now i like them all
um but they're holding back on this
fifth one that's made but they won't
show it and the rumor is is is that
they're not showing it because first of
all they'll lose their ass if they
release it
two some people are saying they might
have to reshoot it again because it
didn't age too well
since all what's happened in the past
[ __ ] election so
we'll see fourth drawdown says in one of
the books bond lights his 80th cigarette
of the day
yeah that sounds good man who can afford
all those cigarettes holy crap
the bond from the books was a hardcore
[ __ ] he was not
a pretty boy and and he wasn't [ __ ]
right he wasn't roger moore
all right when i was a little kid the
first the bond that i did was was roger
moore and it was silly to me it was like
superman
old superman yeah those were a little
goofy just goofy [ __ ]
it just wasn't it was like like
something out of cannonball run or
something
cannonball remember cannonball run yeah
i saw that many many times
yeah the first one and the second one
because it was a sequel
i still you know what i've seen the
cannonball run i've seen kenmore run so
many times
that i probably still know all the words
to east bounding down
yeah how sad is that
but rolling up and trucking
so anyway um can i can i please talk
about this
let's just get the kid all right are you
sure yeah
i'm ready i'm ready are you sure i'm
ready i'm going to get burned again i
know it no you're not going to get
burned i'm ready yes i am
no go ahead okay
i'm going to start talking and then he's
going to go wait wait a minute
all right so flight 19.
this happened uh december 5th 1945.
now again this was just like in the case
of the ghost blimp
this was pretty much just a routine
exercise this was actually a training
exercise so flight 19 actually consisted
of five
avenger torpedo bombers and they were
going out on like a practice bombing run
and um as i said this is december 1945.
so they took off
from the naval air station in fort
lauderdale florida
now the exercise was supposed to take
three hours and it was known as
navigation problem number one
so basically what they were supposed to
do was they were supposed to
fly east um away from the florida coast
and then they were gonna drop some
practice bombs
um at this place called i love that i
love the name of this called hens and
chickens
shoals right so they're gonna drop
practice bombs over there
then they were gonna supposed to turn to
the north and then they were going to
fly over a grand
grand bahama island and then they were
going to turn
toward the southwest and fly back to
base so they're kind of going out in a
sort of triangular motion
they're just going out and it's kind of
like a navigation
exercise because like you mentioned
earlier um you know they didn't have
like
all the really fancy [ __ ] navigation
[ __ ] back then that we have they had
compasses and that was about it
they didn't have it even in my time yeah
okay we had to do land navigation
through [ __ ] map and compass in all
terrain
all weather at all hours it's [ __ ]
hard to do in the dark especially when
visibility is only [ __ ] five meters
in front of you because you're gonna
thicket
so it was done with the pace count and
everything
which it was [ __ ] rough to get into
special forces or [ __ ] do well in
[ __ ] army rangers you had to be a
master at land navigation
it involved an amount of luck but it
also
evolved an amount of endurance because
they usually did this [ __ ] to you when
you weren't when you weren't well rested
you were [ __ ] tired as [ __ ]
and you were doing all kinds of other
stuff long before they ever put you on
these goddamn [ __ ]
field problems it's called a field
problem they call it a problem it's a
problem yeah navigation problem number
one
yeah so it's a navigational test yeah
and
aviation navigation i'm gonna tell you
right now
here's the problem you got a compass
it's in the plane
no gps [ __ ] poor visibility
because there's nothing to see you're
over the ocean so there's no land
navigational features to help you
orient yourself so i already can tell
this is going to suck
go ahead well you know what happens i
know it's i know what happens
so like i said they i mean a bunch of
different squadrons had done the same
this was
like you said it was a test exercise
basically it was a navigation exercise
you're supposed to go out to this
particular spot
drop a bunch of test bombs and then find
your way back to
the base that's what you're supposed to
do it wasn't nighttime or anything like
that it was afternoon it was like
around two o'clock in the afternoon when
they first took off like i said it was
five planes
four of the planes had three dudes in
each of the four planes and then there
was a fifth plane that only had
two dudes now um these were all marines
or navy
navy guys i think they're all in
dauntlesses right
um name atlantis i think it might be a
dauntless tbm avenger was the name of it
they were a
torpedo bomber yeah yeah i know that's
what all the planes were all right
um now these were all uh as far as i
know everybody that was uh
involved in flight 19 was uh you know
quite experienced
they all had at least 300 hours of
flight time if not
much more um the leader of the
expedition or the you know the flight
leader
was lieutenant charles c taylor um
he was an experienced pilot and had been
on several combat missions
in world war two's pacific theater
now so they all take off as i said a
little after two
in the afternoon from fort lauderdale
florida
now the first leg went uh
completely smoothly now like i said they
called this flight 19 because i believe
there had been 18 other
flights that day who were doing the same
thing or similar things because like i
said it was a navigation exercise
so this was just something that they did
all the time so
they take off uh they get to hens and
chicken shoals
at around 2 30 p.m and drop their
practice bombs just like they were
supposed to
now then they turned north which was
supposed to be the second part of the
flight
and then something kind of weird started
happening
now at this stage taylor who was the
flight commander
he started thinking for whatever reason
that the compass on board his plane was
malfunctioning um he might have even had
two compasses on there i think i've seen
some things that said he had two
compasses and he thought they were both
not working
i don't know but he for some reason he
got the idea and said that the compass
wasn't working
so he thought that all the planes
were now flying in the wrong direction
so why he became convinced of that i'm
not entirely sure no one's entirely sure
but he did
now shortly after this happened uh the
weather
started to deteriorate um a front came
in there was like some heavy winds there
was
some rain like some heavy cloud cover
[ __ ] like that
now at this point and they still have
um a lot of the radio transmissions from
the
dudes that were on this flight like
while this [ __ ] was all going wrong
it seems that they all started becoming
disoriented and they weren't really sure
where they were anymore which is
uh which is a little weird yeah so i
think i remember this though
yeah yeah so over the radio one of them
says i don't know where we are
we must have got lost after that last
turn
right yeah now should i jump in if you
want to
okay if i remember correctly
there were some other people that were
involved in this case that i can kind of
give
some more details than what this written
account is saying
from what i remember you maybe
maybe you'll correct me later on
as they were flying out on this leg
they flew over a a chain of small
islands
and and when that happened for some
reason or another
the flight leader misinterpreted that
chain of islands
in a way where he thought it was another
chain of islands
yeah well that happened later that's
just that's what i was just about to
okay talk about okay
all right so yes so it was the islands
that
really [ __ ] him up although like i
said before he had a visual of that
he actually became convinced for
whatever reason no one really knows why
that his compass was malfunctioning yeah
so he somehow
became convinced that they were flying
in the wrong direction yeah easy to do
it sounds crazy but i've been there i've
done that it's very easy to do okay good
yeah so basically so somebody said there
was another dude
a navy flight instructor named
lieutenant robert cox
and he heard some of their [ __ ] over the
radio right because he was flying around
kind of in the area
now he basically said because he heard
the person that said we must have got
lost after that last turn like we don't
know where we are
so this guy overheard it so he radioed
into
the air station and then he contacted
the avengers the planes
and asked them if they needed help
at this stage taylor who was the flight
commander he says to
this guy both my compasses are out
and i'm trying to find fort lauderdale
florida
and supposedly his voice sounded really
he sounded very anxious as you would if
you didn't really know where you were
he was spooked and he says i'm over land
but it's broken i'm sure i'm in the keys
yeah but i don't know how far down yeah
he's wrong now this is very weird
because they had only been out
like an hour no so there would have been
no way
for him to be over the keys so why he
thought he was over the keys
i'm not entirely because if you don't
know like florida like the keys are like
way off the
bottom of the state so he you would have
been like more than 200 miles
off of course he saw terrain features
that he
thought were the keys that's what that's
what's happening that's
yeah he saw train features that made him
think he was over the keys 200 miles
away not possible
not in the time he hadn't been flying
along enough but he was disoriented now
let me ask you this i don't know if you
[ __ ] found this information out
how old is this pilot
um because if i remember 27. there you
go okay
okay he's relatively young he's probably
the oldest guy there
but this is a young man okay
just yeah you guys know that he probably
hasn't been flying all that long a
couple years maybe
yeah i mean like i said they were all
fairly experienced they weren't you know
they weren't a couple years is nothing
compared to 20 or 30 years well sure
all right these guys are young guys yeah
[ __ ] in
internal combustion [ __ ] piston
powered [ __ ] propeller planes
way back in another era before a [ __ ]
gps and stuff flying was
done kind of by gut by feel
you had instruments but you couldn't
trust them and that's [ __ ] really
where all this [ __ ] comes from
these instruments the airspeed the
altitude the compasses and everything
these are all
analog instances instruments um
in a very primitive aircraft and i think
he started really questioning the
readings
of of his instruments he didn't trust
them because a lot of times they weren't
real trustworthy
quality of them wasn't that good so i
kind of put myself in this position when
i was going across the damn causeway
i felt like the whole [ __ ] world was
spinning and i got that
[ __ ] car across that causeway just by
making sure that the [ __ ] yellow
dotted line kept hitting those
that right right [ __ ] side of the
damn
hood of the car you know what i mean
yeah i walked myself across that [ __ ]
15
20 miles of causeway just by looking at
the dotted line
making sure it was in the same spot
because i felt like i was spinning out
of control
yeah and i think that's what it is but
go ahead
go ahead
his his visual what he's seeing is not
matching up with what he had planned in
his head
and it's [ __ ] sending him crazy good
yeah so
basically like i said for some reason he
thinks he's over the keys
yeah which is essentially impossible
because less than an hour earlier he'd
been over henson
chickens shoals which is in the bahamas
and if you didn't know i'm telling you
right now he's panicked
and yeah clearly right um so
as i said he would have had to have been
more than 200 miles yeah
he's lost course which there's just no
way that could happen he's having
almost kind of like a miniature body
experience because there's a lot of
pressure on him he's trying to lead this
flight
and he's panicked because it didn't go
as he expected and he's lost
his orientation in space and time he's
lost
track of how long he's been flying too
which i can understand it but that's a
scary feeling another thing though is
that here's the thing
so some people said yes he was 27 which
you know that's yes that's pretty young
um he wasn't in it he wasn't
inexperienced but you know he was fairly
young still
now he had just transferred um
to fort lauderdale from miami so some
people said oh well maybe he doesn't
really know like the difference between
the bahamas and the keys but
i don't know if people that are not from
florida have like wrote that because
miami and fort lauderdale are only like
a few miles
from one another you know what i'm
saying fort lauderdale is only
30 40 50 miles up the east coast from
miami
i mean they're not that far apart so
it's not like he was coming from a
totally other part of the
state or another part of the country and
didn't know what the [ __ ]
so like when i read that it was like
he'd just been transferred to fort
lauderdale from miami i'm like those two
places are not that
far apart so i don't really know like
why that would be significant i don't
know
but whatever so um so they're thinking
oh well maybe he mistook some of the
bahamas islands for the keys uh because
he never seen the keys before i don't
really know
now the stupid thing about this here's
what happens like when
pilots become disoriented and apparently
they teach you this
you know they taught every single
[ __ ] pilot this they said look if you
ever become disoriented
um you know at least in the atlantic
ocean obviously
they're like then just turn toward the
setting sun clearly because that's
west and that will lead you back toward
land
eventually because that's where the land
is if you're in the atlantic it's to the
west
so just follow the setting sun and like
i said this was afternoon
so that's kind of all he would have had
to do was kind of wait until he could
see
like where the sun was sinking toward
the horizon and he should have just
flown back toward that
direction but for some reason he didn't
really do that
um the thing about it is that
so he thought yeah he thought he was
over the keys
and then he thought he was in the gulf
of mexico
so he shouldn't go farther west because
then he would be [ __ ] in mexico or
texas or whatever
and i don't know like i just don't know
how he could have gotten this
i know how he could have gotten
disoriented like to start with but it
just seemed like he kept compounding
the disorientation he was under a lot of
pressure sure
and uh he started to panic and
he started to [ __ ] lose his
place in [ __ ] space and time
you know what i mean he didn't realize
how he lost track of how long he was
flying
and what direction he was flying in he
became totally
disoriented yeah his panic is what it
was
yeah which i've kind of been there
before on the on during land navigation
with compass and you know what i mean
pace count you'll be like well
you lose you'll lose track of how many
paces you took
and you go like wait a minute hold on
how long is how many paces was that how
far out
am i where am i especially if you're
[ __ ] tired
yeah and you're under a lot of [ __ ]
stress and you're tired
it's easy to lose track and to forget
how long you've been doing something
yeah 20 minutes you know you maybe you
were doing it 20 minutes but it seems
like it was about two or three hours
because you didn't know what you were
where you were going you know what i
mean so it kind of stretches it out
yeah that's what's happening to him i
know so basically so yeah so he thought
i guess that he had flown down over the
keys
yeah and was now over the gulf of mexico
so he thought
i need to turn back toward the northeast
yeah to go back to florida
yeah that's what he thought i guess he's
a fail he he's afraid of failing in the
mission he's got his guys [ __ ]
dependent on him and he's [ __ ] the
pressure's getting to him
and the shitty thing too is that so he
basically said and he was the flight
commander so they all had to listen what
he had to say
he's like no we need to we need to turn
back northeast because that's
the way that florida is yeah and
somebody else one of the other pilots
right
was heard to say damn it if we would
just fly west
we would get home he knew it was that
which they would have yeah
which is really sad but because taylor
was the flight commander they all just
did what he said
right even though some of them knew that
they weren't weren't going the right way
weren't going the right way and
but they just did what he said right so
there was a lack
lack of communication between the team
he should have that guy should have said
hey commander i know you're confused
this is what happened we went this way
for this amount of time and this way for
another amount
all we have to do we are lost but all we
have to do is [ __ ] head in this
heading and we'll hit land yeah and so
the thing about it apparently
it's something real simple but they did
yeah apparently they did
actually talk him into flying west for a
little while
um but then i guess it was just like a
little past 6 p.m and he hadn't seen
land yet so he panicked
so he panicked again and he said no
never mind
um you know we're going back the other
way
he says and like i said they have the
radio transmissions of this he says
we didn't go far enough east he still
thought he was in the gulf of mexico
yeah we may as well just turn around and
go east again
that's what he said they're like no and
yeah the other pilots i guess some of
them kind of argued like i said some of
the
um some of the uh you know recordings
are kind of garbled and stuff it was
time to mutiny but they didn't
but they didn't and that's kind of sad i
mean they'd probably still be alive
um it's it now it has been said that one
of the planes like broke off and flew
in another direction because they were
like [ __ ] this i'm just like i'm not
going because
we're gonna die but i don't know if
that's like
you know confirmed or not because like i
said they never found anybody but most
of them were like okay fine
so they turned back toward the east
again um
so at this point spoiler alert they were
still out in the atlantic
so they were basically had turned toward
the easter they were going farther thank
you thank you thank you
okay that's a question completely
unrelated chiefs or bucks
it sounds like [ __ ] is that is that
sports ball stuff dude sports ball why
you asking
i don't know anything neither that's a
dying business it's a dying business
neither i didn't know anything about it
yeah
back in the old days yeah it's a
diabetic [ __ ] my dad was into
nobody watches that anymore but yeah so
basically what ended up happening was he
thought he was in the gulf so he's like
oh i'm going to turn back this way and
go back to florida
but he was still out in the atlantic so
he's like no i'm going to turn back this
way no i'm going way out into the
[ __ ] atlantic
ocean that's what was happening poor
guys so
yeah so it's like really shitty so um
maybe one plane broke off but they're
not entirely sure because like i said
you know spoiler alert they all
got lost um but most of them
did what he said now at this point they
were still getting radio transmissions
but they started to get kind of fainter
and fainter obviously because he was
going
out into the middle of the [ __ ]
atlantic ocean and um
then their fuel obviously is starting to
run out
yeah and at this point uh one of the
last transmissions they got they heard
taylor
saying all planes close up tight
we'll have to ditch unless landfall when
the first plane drops below
10 gallons we all go down together
that was the last radio transmission
from isn't that creepy well here's the
thing about it what i've seen like some
kind of more paranormal shows like do
stuff about flight 19
and i've noticed that they've added a
lot of radio transmissions like
everything looks strange even the water
looks strange that was not
any part of the official that was made
up
later they didn't say anything like that
um
so no i'm just saying it was just a
navigational
error because uh flight leader got
[ __ ] disoriented and all that
pressure on him he didn't want to
[ __ ] make a mistake
and um he wasn't which it's caused him
to be impatient
that's really what it was they were
losing track of how
the diff the distances they were going
or the time you know what i mean that
the time that had elapsed in the in the
[ __ ] direction
yeah i can understand how it happened
how it would happen kiernan says dang
that's a spooky transmission it is
spooky yeah
we all go down together that was the
last thing but i'm going to tell you
something people
i've seen the same kind of [ __ ] go down
in
land navigation courses on the ground in
the army
it's the same problem for these guys
it's even harder because there's no
terrain features there's nothing to look
at they're looking down the ground you
see waves
uh the only terrain feature would be
this the position of the sun
and if you don't trust your compass and
you're not really sure where you are and
you've had some kind of mental lapse
and you think that you somehow ended up
in the
gulf of mexico which would have been
impossible he's tripping
because you'd have to fly hours over
land before you'd ever end up in the
[ __ ]
gulf of mexico he was just tripping and
he panicked
yeah obviously and then he had a wing of
a wing of [ __ ] fighter bombers with
him or torpedo bombers with him
who were dependent on him and they
trusted what he said
and just followed orders which in a case
like this no you don't follow orders
yeah i'd be like [ __ ] that i'm not
but they all might have been pretty
green you know
i've been talking to them and said
commander what's going on now no no
no no no that's not what's happening but
you see he didn't want anybody to
serpent command from him
making him look bad so there's an
additional pressure on him
but he was a [ __ ] up commander he
should have said guys
i kind of lost track of where we're
going do you guys know
do you guys know yeah help me out here i
would have worded it a different way i
was saying like i'm getting disoriented
where
are we where do you guys think we are i
would have said some [ __ ] i mean
you would think that that would be like
the most obvious thing because
if he thought that his compasses were
not working
yeah you would think well the other
planes their compasses were probably
working presumably
so it's like well what's your what's
your reading i don't i can't trust mine
i think that it's
malfunctioning so what do you guys let's
take a vote and what do you
where do you guys think we are i mean
that seems like the most obvious there
was a lot of pressure on him though i
think to look competent
so he was afraid to communicate with him
and start asking questions
but that's not how you inspire
confidence in a team
you inspire more confidence if you
[ __ ] say
are we headed the right way because this
my compass says this and we've been
flying a long time that's all you had to
say i'm
i don't think my compass is just
functioning correctly like
is your compass functioning where do you
think she said how long we've been
flying we've been flying for 45 minutes
well [ __ ] we should be over by now
shipping you talk to people like that
yeah but i think he was a little uptight
i mean they're a team
you're a team and that's how it always
was
you know what i mean the the reason why
it was so hard during an
army [ __ ] land navigation courses you
were on your own you weren't so there
was no one to ask
right you have you had a
a a grader behind you basically
with clipboard and [ __ ] [ __ ] great in
you so you couldn't ask him [ __ ]
but if you were in a team you'd [ __ ] man
well especially if somebody
[ __ ] it up and you all crash and die
yeah i mean you think that um yeah
somebody better speak up
right and if you're if as long as the
communication was good like
we've been heading on this course for
how long people
35 minutes was [ __ ] we should be seeing
it by now huh
you see it i don't see it where is it
and you go
we'll keep looking there ain't no way we
could have been in the [ __ ] gulf of
mexico or the other guys would be a hell
no we've been flying over the land for
two hours
yeah then we've got to be this got to be
around here somewhere you know i mean
there was a bunch of [ __ ]
he should have done yeah but i'm
critiquing the decisions of a dead man
yeah yeah i mean and then all the other
dudes said he [ __ ] i don't want to
say he killed him
they're kind of [ __ ] partially
[ __ ] responsible because
they didn't speak up and start going no
no no this
isn't right which means that either
they were too [ __ ] cowardly to say
anything against the guy
or they themselves weren't keeping track
and would maybe they didn't know where
they were they might have just been
[ __ ] relying on him to [ __ ] do the
navigation and not really
keeping track of what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] they were doing well we'll just
follow him
which i wouldn't do that and we'll see
no not if my life was on the line
no and and a torpedo bomber had a crew
of two
you had a [ __ ] pilot and you had a
guy in the back well now
the one of the planes had two guys the
other planes had three guys oh the other
guys had three guys right yeah so that's
plenty of dudes to start talking
yeah you know but yes so
it was a navigational error and bad
leadership yeah big time
what it was so basically uh you know
after that creepy last transmission
where he said you know we all go down
together
a couple minutes after that all the
radio communications just
went to static so
and here's what's shitty about this too
so the navy um they start started
sending out search planes
to uh look for them now around
7 30 p.m um
there was another pair of planes like to
pbm mariner flying boats there was a
pair of them
and they took off from fort lauderdale
or just north of
fort lauderdale now the creepy thing
about this is that one of the planes
that went to look for them 20 minutes
after it took off
it vanished off the radar and
they never found the remains of the
plane
or the 13 dudes yeah that were on it
so they even sent a plane up to look for
these dudes and that plane
also disappeared yeah got lost
now some people um as far as i know most
people speculated they
think probably that plane exploded
because um even though they never found
the wreckage and they never found any
bodies of any of the 13 crewmen
but they did find um those fly those
particular types of flying boats
were um this is terrible but they were
um
actually kind of prone to blowing up in
the air so much so that they were called
flying gas tanks
which why would you want to fly in that
i don't know but apparently they were
kind of like
hey those things just blow up in the sky
all the time you know
so they think maybe that that's what's
happened uh what happened to that one
because uh i guess there were some
people on a merchant ship that said that
they had seen something in the sky like
blowing up and so they just presumed
that it was that
even though they didn't um you know find
any wreckage of it or anything
but yeah so that's another thing is like
those 13 dudes got lost
looking for the first set of dudes yeah
because that [ __ ] plane blew up
presumably
um all right michael schafer's going
like well [ __ ]
he said so the guys in this flight who
thought he was wrong followed him anyway
hell dad he'll be do you die or be
court-martialed i'm going to be
court-martialed
they wouldn't even been court-martialed
if you knew how to [ __ ] talk
if you knew how to [ __ ] talk the talk
you would say
our flight wing our flight commander was
[ __ ] up
he he didn't know where the hell he was
going you know
i tried to lead the [ __ ] flight late
fl the wing back
nobody would follow me so uh
they followed him to the death and the
[ __ ] i knew we were going in the
wrong way
i just had to do what i could to salvage
my crew
in the damn back seat yeah that's how
you would play it
that's how you that's how you tell that
you go he wasn't right he was wrong i
did my own calculations there's no way
and he wouldn't listen to me he wouldn't
listen to me [ __ ]
and you know they all died they listened
to his ass they wouldn't punish you
no i'm sure you've come back with your
plane and your crew
and those dudes never came back yep and
then this story that we have here
never would have happened because [ __ ]
like that actually did happen
oh that [ __ ] were crazy you know he
didn't know where he was going i'm back
yeah that's happened before yeah just
you haven't heard about it
you know so yeah so basically like i
said so they had one of the pla one
plane went out to look for them and that
blew up and like
killed 13 people presumably even though
they were never found um
next morning uh the navy sent out uh
like 300 boats and air and planes and
[ __ ] like that to look for
any trace of the planes or any trace of
the people
um and they found they spent five days
uh searching through over three hundred
thousand square miles
of the [ __ ] [ __ ] and they found
nothing not a [ __ ] piece of a plane
not a piece of a life jack nothing they
found
nothing ditched in the water they just
disappeared
ditched in the water they bobbed in the
water for a day or so and died
pretty creepy i mean they looked over
water
they looked over land and as far as i
know to this day they have not found
any single trace of any of the planes or
any of the people
they're under there i mean i'm sure it's
there but they just haven't found them
um yeah so it's like
basically they're still like well
missing
they're just missing cause is unknown
that's all they know navigation layer
reports now
obviously um so this particular
case during the 1960s and 1970s it
become
it became kind of one of the you know
because when you had all those kind of
paranormal writers
like charles burlitz and all them when
they were writing stuff about the
bermuda triangle
this was one of their kind of you know
crown jewel cases
yeah because this did happen in you know
what's popularly known as the bermuda
triangle
so this was kind of one of the ones that
they hyped up so you know like i said
this was on
all those like creepy paranormal shows
about the bermuda triangle and [ __ ]
this was always one of the main cases
that they talked about
um so you know
and it's kind of like oh it's like all
this creepy [ __ ] happened and like i
said
you know all the [ __ ] about the
transmissions of him talking about how
strange the sky and the water looked and
everything like that
that was a later edition i think that
was a later edition
from some of these kind of more
paranormal writers that were trying to
make it seem like it was an alien
abduction
yeah or something like that so he's like
oh i'm we're going into another
dimension or something like that
um he didn't say any of that stuff oh i
didn't feel like i was going into
another dimension driving across that
damn causeway and [ __ ]
felt everything [ __ ] spinning but if
they didn't report that then that's that
effect
wasn't happening to them but they were
lost they were lost yeah i think
basically what happened and the thing
too
is that what they found out later was
that
interestingly um and i think i mentioned
close encounters are the third kind that
uh
that kind of talked about this as well
but like i said this was like a really
famous story
particularly in all the paranormal
literature in the 60s and 70s but one
thing that they found out later from
like witness testimony
was that the the flight commander
charles taylor
um he actually there might have been
something to the fact that he was having
some
kind of problems or he wasn't feeling
very well that day because
they said he turned up to the pre-flight
briefing like kind of late not super
late but they were supposed to
so it ended up like the flight left like
10 minutes later or 15 minutes later
than it was supposed to because he
turned up late
and he also asked his superior officer
if he could be excused from leading the
mission
yeah like witnesses said i just don't
want to take this one out that's what he
supposedly he was already
was overheard to say so i don't know
like he didn't give a reason or anything
but i don't know if he had
hung over or if he was sick or if he
just wasn't feeling it that day or i
don't really know
i remember hearing a story
from one of these more skeptical
programs
that said that that entire [ __ ] wing
that entire flight
had been out the night before [ __ ]
drinking their [ __ ] asses off
and they were all kind of hung over
which that kind of makes a little more
sense
because they weren't really at the top
of their game and they were just kind of
shaming through this thing
and maybe he kind of knew he's like man
i don't really feel all that good
i don't really feel up to it right and
they were just all dependent on him to
get them
through it because they were kind of
sham and they were didn't get much sleep
and they were kind of hung over and like
oh man
i don't want to be here i don't want to
do this [ __ ] today
i know that feeling that and i think
that that right there
they weren't really on top of the game
because
by the time they realized they're in
trouble they go wait
hold on we're lost where are we oh you
don't know where we are
how long we've been flying what
direction nobody really knows
we're [ __ ] yeah oh good [ __ ] because
i wasn't paying attention
it might have been that because [ __ ]
i've seen that before in the infantry
they're like oh [ __ ] wait hold on what
are we doing
oh man [ __ ] this
but you see they're they were in a much
more serious position than we were in
because they're flying
in a [ __ ] expensive airplane over the
ocean
at 200 something miles an hour you know
what i mean
yeah with a limited fuel supply and uh
you're not really sure where you are
it's a lot easier to get lost in those
conditions whether you're just [ __ ]
walking out in the back 40.
yeah yeah because you really get [ __ ]
lost you're like [ __ ] it i'm going to
get something to eat but wait right here
they'll find me yeah i mean when you're
in a plane over the ocean you don't
really have that option
right right like at some point i'm going
to run out of gas and then i'm just
going to go like right into this so the
stakes were like
higher and that's why dude didn't want
to lead the flight
because i remember that now that you
mentioned that that he didn't really
want to leave the flight
they were [ __ ] hung over yeah
or for some reason he just wasn't
feeling it that day and he did actually
try to get out of it
but apparently they told him no wasn't
this like on a monday
or a sunday uh i'm not really sure
actually the blip
the blimp thing was on a sunday if we
know the exact day i'm gonna tell you
whether or not those [ __ ] were
[ __ ] hung over
well i can give you the date you can
look it up okay on a calendar
no the date was well you don't have time
for that like what he was it was
december 5th 1945.
now it was afternoon though when they
went out so it wasn't like early in the
morning
because i feel like the blimp thing that
was like six in the morning like on a
sunday
you know hold on one second
look up
another thing too december 5th december
5th 1945.
okay see what day of the week that was
the fifth
1945
day
wednesday it was a wednesday so it was a
hump day so it wasn't a weekend
one weekend and like i said it wasn't
early in the morning either it was like
it was early afternoon
so i wonder what they were doing maybe
he just was wondering what they were
doing tuesday
i don't know another weird thing too
that
they kind of uh said later on was that
apparently they had um like a rescue
frequency
on their uh zbx receivers like on their
plane
yeah and this if the if these had been
on
in any of the planes then that would
have kind of helped them go toward the
radio towers so they would have been
you know they would have known which
direction to go um
but none of the pilots turned them on
even though they were actually told to
turn them on but none of them were on
so i'm not really sure why none of them
turned those on
because that might have saved their
lives but none of those were on either
even i don't think they were i just got
a feeling they weren't at the top of
their game that day
uh yeah obviously
it's just i don't know it's just it's so
weird
it's so weird how presumably they had
done training exercises like this
before right so i do kind of feel like
i don't know i've never flown a plane in
1945
yeah so it just seems like it seemed
like it would be really easy hey just go
here drop the
bombs turn this way turn back that way
you're home
why would you think that you were over
the keys because the flight commander
said so yeah the flight commander was
[ __ ] spooked and who said so
and they must have said well he must
know what he's talking about because
i don't know where the hell i am i
haven't really been paying attention
that's what that it was that kind of
[ __ ] yeah
and they're going like we're over we're
over the [ __ ] keys
and then how did that happen how that
yeah that is i think that's what it was
these are all young guys and that dude
is in charge
so they're kind of giving deference to
him they're like how do we get over the
keys
and then the other guy's going i'm like
well maybe we are over the key you know
it's [ __ ] like that
yeah another guy's going i don't think
so i don't think that's possible
and some dudes might have been basically
sleeping through it
oh my god [ __ ] it i don't get it yeah
it's like it's just this [ __ ]
where we are i'm just gonna fly i'll
give a [ __ ] where we yeah yeah
yeah there's some of that [ __ ] that was
going on too which that seems a little
i mean like i said you're in an airplane
over the atlantic ocean i'm sure it's
going to be worried about where the hell
i am yeah you might have had dudes you
know
you're like well it's on him i don't
give a [ __ ]
if i could i'm not in charge of this
[ __ ] yeah i'm not in charge of this [ __ ]
if i crash this [ __ ] it's his fault
wake me up when this shit's over
oh man i don't know like i said
yeah these are dudes of course and also
it's
dudes are dumb they just kind of like
it's also 1945.
true and you're dealing with guys that
are in their 20s so yeah
hell yeah [ __ ] right [ __ ] right i
mean this is a whole oh this is a whole
different
era i mean you had 21 year old dudes
flying [ __ ] b-24 liberators over
japan
burning it to a crisp okay
yeah dropping fire on people's children
while they're [ __ ] in bed
burning [ __ ] dresden down and these
guys are in their early 20s
these [ __ ] super expensive bombers
and there was lots of them
because that was the mentality of the
time of course put a 24 year old in
charge of a [ __ ] bomber
we gotta get this [ __ ] done you know
think of that that wouldn't happen today
yeah
you know you don't put a 24 year old
dude in the [ __ ] raptor
well you don't put 24 year old dude they
just don't do that
very much anymore you know what i mean
because now we know that 24 year old
dudes are eating yeah and they're like
go uh
[Laughter]
drop that atomic bomb on that [ __ ]
city over there
you know to do this [ __ ] 24. but they
did that no offense
they did that [ __ ] in the [ __ ] 40s
they didn't really think about it all
that much i guess
well you were an adult at [ __ ] like
probably 17 in those days you know
[ __ ] yeah so just the way it was
interestingly you didn't live long back
then anyway
yeah i guess yeah um interestingly this
guy
listen to this [ __ ] this kind of creeps
me out so in 1991
um there was a bunch of people that were
looking for like
you know sunken pirate ships and
treasure and [ __ ] like that
and they found five
world war ii era avengers in the water
off fort lauderdale so everybody thought
hey
there they are we found flight 19.
guess what that wasn't them it was a
totally different
it was like the [ __ ] the uh
the serial numbers were not the same as
the one of the
of flight 19 of the lost patrol so isn't
that [ __ ] crazy like no these are
five other planes
that [ __ ] off of fort lauderdale but
so yeah so this ended up being six
planes lost
because there was five planes in the
original thing and then one of the [ __ ]
one of the planes blew up
like on like looking for them um 27
dudes
27 dudes and they have not found a
single trace
of the planes or the people none of the
27 people
who [ __ ] knows they wrote that [ __ ]
off they just wrote it off
well it's back in the days where you
could write some [ __ ] off you're like
yeah we lost all these airplanes but
we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
write that off well what else can you do
i mean
scott says 24 year old dudes shouldn't
be in charge of a starbucks
[Laughter]
it was um yeah it's like i'm not real
sure
i'm not real sure 34 or 44 year old dude
should be in charge of anything
either just another time
it kills me it kills me when i think
about i mean i know people matured
faster back then probably
um because you know the world was a very
different place and you just didn't live
long
yeah well and it was just kind of like
once you were
18 years old i mean a lot of people had
already like gotten married and [ __ ]
yeah i started having kids and [ __ ] like
that
here's the thing in the 40s there was a
concept of a teenager they had a little
bit of a teenager culture it wasn't much
but you have to understand what was
going on decades before that
in the 1800s you put six-year-old kids
to work in
factories and [ __ ] made them [ __ ]
[ __ ] dig coal
yep you know there was this thing as
childhood
yeah once you were like old enough to
walk around you could talk then you
could work
yeah and they put your ass to [ __ ]
work right away
so they didn't really wait you know yeah
they didn't have they didn't have
concept of childhood
so of course during this during the
second
world war you're gonna put a [ __ ] 23
year old dude inside of a [ __ ] b-17
where the crew dudes in their [ __ ]
very early 20s
and then take thousands of them [ __ ]
and [ __ ] fly them over germany japan
drop fire on people you know it's just
what you did
wasn't anything unusual about that no no
that's what everyone was doing that's
what
everybody was doing yeah then they came
back [ __ ] tore the place up [ __ ]
drinking them drinking themselves death
and [ __ ] having fun
watching football games yeah
all this nfl and all this [ __ ] big
[ __ ] you guys are all into about [ __ ]
sports ball and everything i was never
really a big fan of
sports ball gave two [ __ ] shits about it
that was a corporate [ __ ] response to
the second world war that [ __ ] did not
happen
until dudes came back from the second
world war they're like we need some kind
of some [ __ ] to see that's sort of
combat like
sure and the corporate powers [ __ ]
did everything they could to pump money
in these gigantic [ __ ]
stadiums half of them gone go look at
that [ __ ] on youtube
oh man now i'm looking into this [ __ ] on
youtube these gigantic stadiums like
[ __ ]
that are in all these different states
that are all abandoned and were torn
down
like that [ __ ] doesn't exist anymore
when i was a kid i remembered those
[ __ ] stadiums they're all gone
a lot of them are gone why they you
couldn't fill them they couldn't
they couldn't make money with those
things because people started watching
sports on tv
and now you get people to watch sports
and you and i understand it you know
what i mean [ __ ] because
jenny's the same way we watched we we
grew up
watching our dads sitting there [ __ ]
lazy ass dan on the couch
dads and grandpas dads and grandpas and
uncles world war ii [ __ ] and
vietnam war [ __ ] sitting down
on the couch watching [ __ ] sports
ball
watching black dudes beat the [ __ ]
brains out of each other on [ __ ]
my dad was born in nascar yeah that's
just everything you know but he watched
me with just like oh yeah
yeah yeah and i was just and i would
look at that [ __ ] just the sound of
those games would drive me [ __ ] crazy
yeah it wasn't and i was like man that
[ __ ] [ __ ] sucks
and i just thought they were [ __ ]
just lame lame games
and that's why that shit's vanishing
it's it it it's a
it's it's a it's a cultural thing it was
a [ __ ]
generational thing and if you look at
the [ __ ] white dudes that [ __ ]
look at sports ball
those guys are the guys that could never
play that game they're these little
[ __ ] overweight
balding [ __ ] that yeah
my blacks are stronger than your blacks
that's really [ __ ] what they were
doing that's
that's how
you like to be able to be like this is
my team and we're gonna whip your team's
ass
yeah it's a thing in mississippi it was
literally my blacks are stronger than
your blacks
because there weren't any white people
on those teams
dan says people only watch nascar for
the wrecks don't they yeah i kind of
feel like yeah yeah yeah
i mean you know i do you remember
because i grew up in daytona beach which
obviously if you don't know is like a
humongous [ __ ] nascar
hub because that's where the daytona
international speedway is where a lot of
the major races are
and um i still remember when [ __ ]
dale earnhardt
bought it on one of those rick and he
was like one of the most famous ones
and uh yeah he [ __ ] died at that one
race he's like hit a wall and like
[ __ ]
and i remember it was like a really
weird it was really weird because i feel
like people were like yeah
wreck and then he's like oh he died now
we kind of have to feel bad oh [ __ ]
yeah and it was just like a really weird
like it was a weird time
i hated all that [ __ ] yeah i didn't do i
hated all that [ __ ]
uh growing up in the 80s watching the
way
the people of that time responded to
those [ __ ] games to me it just looked
racist as [ __ ] it just did
sorry t that [ __ ] looked racist as [ __ ]
just based on the fact of [ __ ] what
what why people were saying about it
you know and i wanted nothing to do with
that [ __ ] and they got people that still
love those
those sports but not me i that's not how
i
interpreted them i mean didn't you feel
that way
yeah a little bit i think i just kind of
like i don't know just
i guess sports was never all that
interesting to me because i was kind of
more into
punk rock and i thought they were racist
horror stories and stuff
yeah they kind of raced yeah yeah they
were actually it was basically white
people betting on [ __ ] black
gladiators
that's really what it was yeah yeah it
did have that actually
very much so i mean not so much like i
said you know my dad was more than
nascar and that was mostly like white
dudes watching other like
even more rednecky white dudes like just
like driving around in a circle
but um because you know no i'd go to
this [ __ ] super ball of things i
wouldn't say it but superman
dad it wasn't so much my dad think it
was all my dad's friends
and you get [ __ ] 15 20 [ __ ] white
dudes doing a big old [ __ ]
party with all these [ __ ] barbecues
and [ __ ] and they're watching the
[ __ ] super bowl
and you know this is back in the [ __ ]
early 80s to mid 80s that's
[ __ ] right that [ __ ] was racist it
was just a [ __ ] it's a bunch of white
dudes
betting on black gladiators whose blacks
are stronger than other people's blacks
and
and just looking up man i didn't like
that [ __ ] at all just gave a bad taste
in my mouth and that shit's kind of
going away i mean [ __ ] nfl and
nba and all this it's being replaced by
[ __ ] video games really those [ __ ]
videos video game sports
and some people say oh that's [ __ ]
terrible because you know you have black
people making a living off of that
i can understand that that yeah black
people make a living off of it but
[ __ ]
you had you had germans and [ __ ]
goths
[ __ ] making a living off of being
gladiators inside the roman
arena too all right but that didn't mean
it was good
i just didn't think any of that [ __ ] was
good scott's talking about nascar being
my hillbilly is faster than yours
[Laughter]
at least it was machine oriented and the
same
hillbilly that crashed that car was the
same hillbilly that burnt to a crisp
and it was the same hill billy's up
there [ __ ] it the nascar didn't have
the the racist element to it i mean
every now and then like one of the tires
would come off and like slice into the
crowd
and kill a bunch of people you know that
would happen
yeah it's i had a like seriously the
the [ __ ] daytona international
speedway was like
a couple of miles from my house yeah so
whenever they had
a big race you know the [ __ ] traffic
was [ __ ]
you couldn't go anywhere it was really
uh it was really kind of a nightmare
so that's why i'm just real i i'm just
real thing i don't like the whole
redneck thing i don't like the whole
hillbilly thing because i grew up in
daytona and it's just like i'm so
so over it you know like i said i was a
horror kid i was
i hated all this i was a punk rock a
little new wave kid i
you know those kids were beating my ass
when i was little you know
making fun of me so it's like i'm not
i'm not
into it i'm not you know you can keep
your mullet you can keep your country
music you can keep all that [ __ ]
the food's good oh that's that's all
xanada said that that that the attitude
that i saw was a southern thing it may
have been back in the day
he said they didn't have that in the
south the southern interpretation
of professional sports was different
from the northern interpretation it
probably probably was
but i don't know you start stripping
away the lies that people tell
themselves it may have been the same
thing
to me it was all like gladiatorial
sports
the only sports i actually used to like
to watch were like the winter sports
like [ __ ] ice skating and uh
what like like what is that called like
the [ __ ]
were they all getting that little tiny
thing and go through all the shh
not toboggan what the [ __ ] is that
i like all the winter olympics i like
that yeah because we didn't have winter
in florida so it was neat like seeing
all the [ __ ] skiing and [ __ ]
xander the sports i was talking about
was mostly
bobsled thank you yeah bob the sports i
was talking about was mostly [ __ ]
football
football was the biggest one that
[ __ ] to me was
light gladiatory gladial [ __ ]
sports boxing to us to a certain amount
um never likes basketball at all i
always thought
basketball was just ridiculous um
most of that [ __ ] to me just it was just
[ __ ] ridiculous
i couldn't stand the sound of it you
know
the thing that always pissed me off
about football and i did i feel like a
lot of
um europeans you know who are more into
soccer will say this too it's like
football
especially american football like when
you see it on tv
honestly it stops like every couple of
minutes
especially towards the end of the game
and then they just like put play
commercials and [ __ ] like that it just
seemed like the
games took for [ __ ] ever and like
nothing
happened and it was just kind of like
you know it's like my dad would be
watching it and i just be like
is anything like happening or are they
just gonna stop every minute and then
like have commercials because i just
well i remember in the remember in the
70s and the early 80s though the [ __ ]
football was a lot more violent than it
ended up being later
so i can understand why they liked it uh
and also
they were betting on it so that had a
lot to do with it too
was how much money you had bet on it i
thought
all that [ __ ] oh i think all that shit's
[ __ ] out of date i just think it's
all out loaded
i mean the the future is what they call
esports i think
yeah people watching other people play
video games yeah
but emily they got guys guys [ __ ]
playing esports making more than what
you would call professional with
professional football players they're
making more than that
and that's [ __ ] amazing to me
yeah that a dude [ __ ] makes more
than a [ __ ] pro ball player just
playing [ __ ] video games
mark says i like watching grundman punch
each other's titties
so is there anything more to say about
this [ __ ] um
i don't think so we actually got to the
end of it like in a reasonable amount of
time even though you did kind of go off
and like talk about different stuff
but that's okay it's only here in
florida
it's only 8 19 p.m which means i have
more than an hour
before i have to do the other show and
i'm still
sober which is good um
you know see what else is going on there
draw a dog says you used to love roller
derby yeah they're like
i could watch roller derby i liked i
liked [ __ ]
uh fake wrestling all right
now what i'm into now what i'll watch
i'll wake up in the morning
i'll [ __ ] drink coffee and i'll watch
it on youtube is something called
stardom and stardom is a japanese
youtube channel with a bunch of these
little japanese girls that go in there
well they're not all japanese some of
them are like one of them is part
italian another one is the [ __ ]
australian girls
and they'll go in there and they'll do
pro wrestling kind of like fighting with
my family they'll do that
and uh it's obviously fake
as cute as [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's these little [ __ ] teddy
bear-shaped [ __ ] japanese girls that
have got to be [ __ ] 4 foot 11.
and these [ __ ] really [ __ ] outfits
pretending to fight each other
and they pretended to be tired and like
they got oh i got my ass with
and it's just it's just cute as [ __ ] and
they got the [ __ ]
they got the [ __ ] edited so it's only
like 15 or 20 minutes at a time
so it's not like you're watching a whole
hour of it you know what i mean
you just see little things some of them
speak english and some of them don't
it's just called stardom
and and and and i like that better
because yeah he's always watching that
when i go
yeah start him he just sits he sits
there we have like here's the bed and
then like there's a little bench at the
end
and he's just sitting there with his
little coffee cup in the morning in the
morning watch it like watch it because
every day yeah every day they'll post
like two or three of them
sometimes they'll have subtitles so you
know what they're saying but you really
don't need the subtitles because you
know they're all it's all [ __ ]
they're
they're like [ __ ] i'm gonna i'm gonna
just defeat you the next time
next time i see you are they [ __ ]
talking one another oh there's [ __ ]
talking you know
i love it sometimes in the [ __ ] cat
in the captions it's like it's a little
bit better than you imagined it
but it's just it's like watching roller
derby
yeah you know what i mean i do like i do
like i do like roller derby
i like to watch girls beat the [ __ ]
their girl
what makes stardom so great is that
nobody gets hurt because you know
it's girls pretending to beat the [ __ ]
yeah well that's like you know any kind
of wrestling it's like you do have to
know how
to do it so yeah it's an art form it is
so people don't actually get hurt there
are like safety measures in places
it takes you right back to when you're a
kid you're watching ultraman
or [ __ ] you know godzilla they just
don't have
they just have a different costume on
yeah yeah but that's what they're doing
and they're [ __ ] so short you know
what i mean they're not
they're not big muscular or anything
michael shafer just said tom likes them
because they're the same height as he is
no
[Laughter]
most of them i don't even think are five
feet tall they're more like [ __ ] 411.
that's pretty that's even shorter than
me and i'm pretty [ __ ] sure yeah
they're tiny
i mean do you go to korea or japan or
anything like that you see how small a
lot of them are they're very small
they're very small yeah and they got the
little [ __ ] cute outfits with the
[ __ ]
little frilly skirt and a [ __ ] some
kind of head head dress with maybe
caddies cat ears or some stupid [ __ ] or
horns
and you can definitely tell the good
guys from the bad guys
yes the good guys are always some kind
of a cutesy motif
and the bad guys are always some kind of
like heavy metal
gothic looking motif you know what i
mean so it's it's obvious who's who and
they're doing it in
their tag teaming in teams and [ __ ] and
it's got good music
and whatever you know what i mean and
it's it's not meant to be
the internet is a magical place
internet's a magical you can find pretty
much
anything you want yeah and it's not
meant to be taken seriously
that's [ __ ] funny i'll just sit down
and watch some of that stuff
i do like it's cute yeah i do like
watching girls beat the [ __ ] out of each
other it's more interesting to me than
dudes beating the [ __ ] out of each other
because they're always doing well they
do the same [ __ ] you did back in the old
wwe
you know they pretend like they're
hitting any others yeah oh my god oh my
god yeah you're like [ __ ] that would
have killed her
[Laughter]
yeah it's fun you'll see it and then
likes the same ones over and over again
there's only like maybe 15 of them so
it's always the same ones and they've
got yeah it's like glow like gorgeous
ladies around yeah and
there's evidently a story going on well
yeah that's what wrestling has
you have your [ __ ] yeah you have your
heel you have your [ __ ] yeah
you know it's it's all like a narrative
yes you guys want to check that out it's
on youtube it's called stardom
stardom tila said she found it yeah
stardom's cute man i like stardom
mark navarro said i wonder how many
times jenny has walked in on tom
flexing in front of the mirror i don't
flex in front of yours
more than once oh well wait a minute oh
wait a minute yes you do
no okay yeah but that's not like
something i'm doing in private jenny's
there
yeah that's what that's what i'm
checking it's not it's not yeah it's not
yeah then he's asking me like is that
angle i have to i have to come
and like examine it and i'm like how's
that angle going is that is it angle
coming in
okay i'm gonna get that angle in there
yeah he's always asking me stuff
yeah wait do i have a little bit today
as i'm going is that titty getting
bigger
yeah that [ __ ] feel that [ __ ] is it
getting bigger
you wait till i go on [ __ ] time yeah
see there's like nothing secret no i'm
not a secret about this [ __ ] no he
doesn't
know he has no shame no neither do i
really no
i'm trying to fix [ __ ] trying to fix it
trying to work [ __ ] out
but uh although see i think you notice
that stuff more than i do
because i'm not it's not like i'm
looking at all the angles
like every single day so i don't know i
know what to look for i look at a man
like he's a [ __ ] side of beef
like he's a cow he's like
[Laughter]
you suck you suck you suck so you know
what i mean strawdog 78 says jenny how's
my symmetry yeah that's that's that's
right that's pretty good that's what i'm
doing
he's always asking yeah it's not just
that it's like
you wait till i get on this [ __ ] does
my hair look [ __ ] up doesn't matter
yeah well i'm always cutting my hair and
[ __ ] and i'm getting her to cut it and
stuff
yeah i got it is that [ __ ] right there
right i just got i gotta cut the back he
just decided yeah
because he can't really see the back but
the uh
[ __ ] no man you guys are [ __ ] you
got me wrong i'm not
i'm not [ __ ] embarrassed or shy about
any of this [ __ ] it's part of my [ __ ]
repertoire
it's the normal thing that i do you wait
till i [ __ ] get on that [ __ ]
exogenous testosterone i'm gonna [ __ ]
go like you're gonna be just rampaging
all over this [ __ ] no
we're gonna be shooting [ __ ] porn
again we're gonna have to hard to start
a whole new channel because i'm gonna be
going
you can start a whole channel i'm going
i'm to go back to like
i would like to the test level of
[ __ ] five
14 year olds five of them yeah
five of them combined no i just that's
not what i'm gonna do can you imagine
the smell
speed like a stinky skunk man and all
that [ __ ] horrible i have two
brothers i know i know the smell of
teenage boys [ __ ] yeah i'm not gonna
i don't think i'm gonna go that i'm
gonna get my blood work done
and i'm gonna see exactly what the
levels are and we're gonna see what i'm
gonna do and i'm gonna
i'm i don't think i'm gonna push it up
into superhuman levels but
i'm gonna put that [ __ ] into into human
levels young human levels
a young human yeah because you guys
don't know maybe you guys don't know
what i'm talking about
some of these dudes if you looked at
their [ __ ] blood results they are at
super human levels yeah
and you see i'm not ravaged by [ __ ]
um
drug use or [ __ ] um i haven't used
bunches of [ __ ] you know anabolics
and stuff
so my liver is in good condition i could
[ __ ] i could go crazy
i'm [ __ ] in good enough condition
where i could i could
i could go [ __ ] crazy that [ __ ] if i
want to
because i don't have a history of abuse
of it but i don't want to do that
i want it to be more just [ __ ] normal
levels
you know what i mean yeah as far as i
know right now
i'm gonna see how good it feels although
it would kind of be funny to see you
like walking around the show like that
like that gorilla video we watched
something yeah that [ __ ] girl when
that girl thought he was all [ __ ]
sexy and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
flirting did you guys know that male
gorillas flirt
and they flirt with girls i've seen it
happen hell yeah they do
what's that one we watch it's like a
it's like it's 24 hours i guess it's
kind of like a camera that's
on these gorillas that are in this
enclosure at whatever zoo it is
and it's like fascinating to watch them
but i did like a long time ago i was at
animal kingdom here in orlando
and they have a big guerrilla enclosure
and i swear to god man the gorilla there
one of them the big male yeah he was
very like when enough people would
gather around like the window like
looking at him
he he went to the back of the enclosure
and laid down like this he was like
ladies
he was like laying like that with his
hand up on his head it was so
[ __ ] funny testosterone's a hell of a
dream i mean he was very clearly being
like drink me and
yeah here they got they got they got a
gorilla in [ __ ] japan you can see
them on
on youtube but these japanese girls
[ __ ] just love this [ __ ] they're
so cute
young male gorilla he's about [ __ ] 15
16 17.
and uh there were all these japanese
girls taking pictures and waving to him
and he's
drinking this [ __ ] in he's like just
basking in the love of all this like
these japanese girls who just [ __ ]
love this thing
but and there was another video [ __ ] was
just a trip
they got a little white girl [ __ ]
with little short shorts and her little
[ __ ] sandals on and she's got
[ __ ] gorgeous legs and she's got her
[ __ ]
tablet and she's showing this young male
gorilla he's just [ __ ] puffed up and
[ __ ]
and he's looking at the [ __ ] tablet
and every time she turns the tablet away
he's like change it he wants to see
another pitcher
yeah and he's just sitting there looking
at her legs
[Laughter]
and i'm going i feel you bro because she
was cute she was real cute
but there's it's a universal thing they
are so human-like
they're very human which is probably why
they shouldn't be in captivity no
testosterone is a [ __ ] hell of a
[ __ ] thing he's just sitting there
just looking at her going
gosh she's cute and it's funny because
it's trans species but
i guess it doesn't matter close enough i
guess they know what cute is
yeah yeah and they and you've said too
and we've seen video too of like um some
people will bring in like
tablets or phones with pictures of
gorillas or the gorillas
on them or like other kind of apes yeah
and if you show them to the
like he gets it he's kind of like oh
that's nice it's like then he moves his
little fingers like
he's like next one move it to the next
one let's see what the next one looks
like yeah
i think they're not done no it's a
different kind of intel does i think
they're what 84
or 86 percent genetically identical
96 is it 96 at least okay they're real
close
oh yeah they're not human but they're
real close and you can tell like in
their facial expressions the way they
yeah i mean that one that we watch
sometimes it's kind of like it's a big
silverback
male and then there's like a little baby
one yeah
and the way they play and stuff like
that is just like a dad and a kid
you know what i mean you can tell
exactly what they're thinking you can
tell
exactly what their little facial
expressions are you can tell all that
kind of stuff yeah
it's just super super funny all right so
when is your next show
in an hour and a half i'm gonna go ahead
and shut this one down so you
yeah better i gotta get ready for the
next show
and i'm pretty sober which is good
um and we have to go check on where they
said
trans species relationships are the next
frontier
yeah they just get [ __ ] out
there demonstrating for that [ __ ]
release those gorillas the women are
hungry
[Laughter]
[ __ ] gorillas are pretty cute i gotta
say
yeah [ __ ] sophie goes is it
bestiality if the gorilla
is instigating huh
yeah it is it's it's
you can see it there on youtube i mean
the girl's probably about 17 i would say
probably
and she's got little short shorts on
little [ __ ] sandals
and a little [ __ ] t-shirt on she's
stretched out in front of the [ __ ]
window
and as a man i know when a girl's trying
to [ __ ] look cute she is trying to
look cute
right this gorilla is [ __ ] responding
and he's a young girl probably a little
bit younger than her maybe the same age
and he's looking at her tablet but every
time she changes he goes down and looks
at her legs
and it's going and then
she looks back at her again she's going
god she's cute
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you know they're a human they're
human-like animal
they are yeah well like i said they're
very very genetically similar
yeah teal asked if it was a live show
yeah as far as i know it's a live show
and i think it's two hours so i'm gonna
have to be on from 10 to midnight
and i'm going to be talking about some
unsolved murders
so that'll be fun hopefully yeah [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] with me about you so tom
michael says tom's gonna get back me now
you only get back me from anabolics
you know what bacne is right yeah back
acne
yeah you start [ __ ] with anabolics
you'll get a real greasy kind of sweat
that comes out of you like you're going
through puberty
it's like a second puberty bunch of acne
and [ __ ]
but like i said i don't want to go on
anabolics um
i wouldn't mind going on [ __ ] tests
but i wouldn't i'm not going to go on
anabolics
now if i ever did go on anabolics i
would do a jack lalanne style
in other words when i'm starting to
approach my 60s
if i were to somehow if i were to able
to get a hold of them legally i was
going to say if i was able to legally
get a hold of anabolics i would maybe
consider
[ __ ] um very mild
cycles of it as i was working out
just and see how it went because
the anabolic compounds their
testosterone mimickers
they are very close to testosterone
the body recognizes them as testosterone
but they're a lot better
they're a lot better at
healing muscle building and rebuilding
rebuilding damage the average person
just walking around doesn't really
[ __ ] know what is up they just
hear things in the media they don't
really know what drugs are for they
don't know how they work
and a lot of doctors even you'll find
out don't really know how that kind of
stuff works and they have
kind of um what do you call it
um stereotypes
about how that stuff works there's
there's
proof that or evidence coming from human
testing in other words guys who [ __ ]
used these things not officially but
used them
that anabolics as you're [ __ ] aging
can help fight off some of the [ __ ]
real bad effects of
of aging see if you look at people as
they age
they a lot of people will hold out they
age pretty well
until they get to be a mid 60s around 70
around that time all of a sudden
boom they just drop off that looks like
a hormonal crash like the body isn't
producing the amount of hormones
that normally would in order to keep a
[ __ ] healthy
reproductive type body here's the weird
thing
we see health when we see health a lot
of times what we're seeing is we're
seeing the effects of
we're seeing the signals of a person
who's reproductive
okay person that could have children to
us that looks attractive
when you get to a certain age your body
starts saying well i guess it's because
of
[ __ ] uh uh evolution
the human body says well reprod being
reproductive
is biologically or metabolically
expensive
and at this point in our subject's life
he's already reproduced
so let's go ahead and shift resources
away from reproduction
and we'll shift it more towards life and
just protecting the brain or something
whether or not you actually need that to
happen
in the body i don't think that's really
known
but it seems to be that if you win that
before that shift happens
if you introduce things like anabolics
and new kinds of hormones
that shift away never really happens
so the person seems to continue on
normally
yeah they age but they don't really look
that aged
they look still look attractive um
and you know that's evident in the
people that have done it
you know like i said look at tony basil
i guarantee you she's still on estrogen
and she's very active and where do you
get estrogen you can [ __ ] get it the
same way from [ __ ] like you can from
a [ __ ] trt clinic they'll give it to
women too
it's just a birth control pill with
estrogen in it that's all it is
the right dose and yeah it'll keep you
younger looking
um we all die but um technology can help
you age out a lot better
and um if the technology's there why not
use it
i mean wouldn't you think and why not
sure sure i mean
the human is just the human body is just
a living machine
and we've been fixing machines forever
eventually when the technology is good
enough
you probably could defy death
we're doing it already you're just not
realizing it because just regular
anything that is medical that helps you
live longer is life extension
and we're living longer and better than
humans have ever
lived because of this technology
eventually you'll be able to counter a
lot of
a lot of the effects of aging now this
let's be honest people will these rich
[ __ ] allow the average
[ __ ]
access to this no they're trying to
reduce the population
so they're not going to tell you
everything about this are they doing it
yeah they're doing it
they're doing it so it behooves you to
find all this stuff out
and and figure out whether or not you
want to spend money on this
and uh but eventually for right now
looks like
things like hormone replacement and
anabolics
done properly with the right training
schedule
and it's never going to be one of these
kind of things where you just sit around
do nothing
and take a pill and it fixes you you'll
never you'll never have that
you have to stimulate muscle growth and
rebuilding through
weights or or maybe
weights the best if if not that you're
always going to have [ __ ] aerobics
too aerobics will help
but uh [ __ ] we got to end this show and
i'm just keep talking about health i'm
asking questions but
i know because you just i'm just like
you keep on going and i'm like it's
getting what they're talking
to they're talking i got stuff i gotta
do yeah
yeah and i have to go to the bathroom we
have to find out where a little pookie
went to
but yeah so uh we will be back tomorrow
at 3 p.m
est probably talking about um oculus the
mike flanagan movie because we just
watched it recently
and that's still new enough to be a
matinee show because i think that's came
out in 2013 or something
so uh we'll probably talk about that
and uh if it's not that late where you
are
then head on over to into i don't know
how they
want you to pronounce it into the para b
normal into the pair of b
normal like that there's a b in the
middle okay so i'm gonna be on there
at 10 p.m eastern standard time i think
for two hours and i'm going to be
talking about unsolved
murders like that were in my faceless
villain book
and so that'll be from 10 to midnight
and i'm pretty sure it's a live show so
i gotta do that in a little while
um so we will see you guys again
tomorrow
remember like share subscribe do all
that kind of stuff go to our patreon
page you guys know
um so you done you sure they're asking
you said tom what about the [ __ ]
uh the liver damage with the amount of
booze that you're drinking mixed in with
all these [ __ ] compounds
no we don't drink as much as you guys
think we do
well [ __ ] twice a week maybe and it's
not really that much
uh but also you have to understand that
i have not lived a life of abuse
so um no no i'm [ __ ] i've seen my
[ __ ]
i've seen my lit my liver [ __ ]
numbers from the last time i had blood
work done a year ago or so my [ __ ] my
my liver is [ __ ] fantastic
you compare my liver to [ __ ] billy
idol
and and it's like comparing the [ __ ]
liver of a baby to a [ __ ] zombie
okay sure so i'm nothing as bad as those
guys
[ __ ] that they were doing well yeah some
of the guys back then i'm like amazed
they're still alive
yeah they were taking [ __ ] [ __ ]
booze and heroin and all this other [ __ ]
so no i'm [ __ ] wide open i can i can
um i'm in good enough shape to do
anything i can do anything i want
yeah it'll it'll be cool it'll be all
right yeah but yeah
so uh we'll see you guys again tomorrow
and uh thanks everybody for dropping by
and hanging out with us
and uh so that's it right yeah that's it
okay
just making sure all right we'll see you
guys tomorrow
bye